la séance est ouverte le contendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves d'usage l'ordre du jour appelle
une déclaration du gouvernement suivie
d'un débat en application de l'article
50-1 de la
Constitution monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs lorsque le Sénat est faible la
République est faible lorsque le Sénat
est fort la République est forte et
lorsqu'il n'y a
[Applaudissements]
pas et lorsqu'il n'y a et lorsqu'il n'y
a pas de Sénat il n'y a plus de
[Applaudissements]
République mots ces mots ce ne sont pas
les
miens mais je l'ai fait mien mais je
l'ai fait
mien ce sont ceux du recteur préot h
homme de droit de conviction et sénateur
aux premières années de notre 5e
République ces mots je le dis je l' fait
mien le Sénat et la chambre de la
réflexion et du long terme c'est la
chambre du débat d'idée et de la
construction de compromis c'est la
chambre du respect de nos institutions
comme des convictions c'est la voix des
territoires des élus des préoccupations
du quotidien je n'imagine pas la
République sans le bicamérisme et plus
encore dans une période de crise dans
une période où les événements se
multiplient et les défis
s'additionnent nous avons besoin du
Sénat besoin de sa capacité à incarner à
la fois la hauteur de vue et la
proximité avec les Français m'adresser à
vous c'est m'adresser à tous nos
territoires de l'hexagone et des
outrmèes dans leur unité et leur
singularité m'adresser à vous c'est
aussi affirmer la volonté du
gouvernement de travailler et de
construire en commun au sein de mon
équipe pourtant la plus resserrée de la
5e République je compte un ancien
sénateur avec Christophe Béchu un
sénateur actuel aujourd'hui au
gouvernement avec Sébastien le cor nu je
compte des maires qui savent
l'engagement la passion mais aussi les
contraintes qu'exige ce mandat je compte
avec Catherine vutrain notamment avec
Rachid adati pour la mairie du 7e
arrondissement je compte des élus locaux
j'en suis moi-même un depuis 10 ans des
élus locaux qui aiment leur territoire
comme ils aiment notre pays et veulent
s'engager pour lui ensemble à la tête de
cette équipe je viens devant vous
aujourd'hui prêt à m'engager
m'engager à travailler avec le Sénat sur
tous les textes et dans toutes les
circonstances j'y ai tenu comme ministre
des compte public comme ministre de
l'éducation nationale j'y tiens
aujourd'hui comme premier ministre et
nous le ferons avec l'ensemble de mon
gouvernement je m'engage à avancer à
l'écoute de nos élus et de nos
territoires derrière le cap fixé par le
président de la République c'est à leur
contact que j'ai aussi construit les
constats et les solutions de ma
déclaration de politique générale c'est
avec eux que je veux gouverner et
décider je serai un premier ministre de
terrain à la tête d'un gouvernement de
terrain je m'engage enfin à agir
toujours pour la simplification le bon
sens et le quotidien des Français que
nous disent les élus que nous disent nos
concitoyens que nous disent les
agriculteurs ces derniers jours qu'il
croule trop sous les règles sous les
normes qu' les Brid les brim et empêche
notre pays d'avancer alors ma méthode
sera simple dialoguer écouter et décider
décider de mesur clair et
compréhensibles décider pour que les
choses changent vraiment toujours pour
les Français monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs le cri de colère exprimé par
nos agriculteurs ces derniers jours est
le reflet des doutes des exaspérations
des colères mais aussi des espoirs et
des opportunités de notre pays la France
est une grande patrie agricole
l'agriculture fait partie de l'âme de
notre pays elle fait partie de nos
racines de notre héritage chaque
territoire a son emblème qui fait écho
aux cultures et aux élevages et si les
mots pays et paysan se ressemblent tant
c'est parce que l'un ne va pas sans
l'autre je n'imagine pas la France sans
son agriculture et la France ne serait
pas la France sans ses agriculteurs
pourtant nos agriculteurs souffrent ils
incarnent tous les défis d'une France
qui doute ils sont le visage du travail
et du dévouement ils ne connaissent ni
vacances ni véritable repos et pourtant
leur rémunération n'est pas toujours à
la hauteur de leur engagement à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils apportent à notre
pays alors oui tous les Français des
classes moyennes se reconnaissent en eux
tous ces Français qui ne peuvent compter
que sur leur travail mais doivent
compter chaque euro à la fin du mois nos
agriculteurs sont les premières victime
du dérèglement climatique ils subissent
le gel la sécheresse les inondations les
tempêtes alors oui toute notre société
se retrouve dans leurs inquiétudes nos
agriculteurs croulent sous les normes
chacune de leurs initiatives peut
relever du parcours du combattant
chacune de leurs actions est réglementée
et surréglementée alors oui chacun de
nos concitoyens partage leur volonté de
respirer de se débarrasser de procédures
inutiles de voir leurs initiatives
libéré de la bureaucratie nos
agriculteurs s'interroge sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne ils
savent ce que la PAC leur apporte mais
n'accepent pas plus que nous certaines
de ces lourdeurs alors oui nos
compatriotes s'identifient à cette
interrogation nos compatriotes qui
savent très bien que nous sommes plus
forts grâce à l'Europe mais exige que
l'Union européenne soit plus proche plus
efficace et plus protectrice je le dis
sans détour nous devons aussi prendre
notre part j'en prends l'engagement nous
ne surtransposerons pas les normes
européennes nous
devons être au côté de nos agriculteurs
et nous ne pouvons pas nous-mêmes leur
mettre des boulets au pied dans une
compétition européenne et mondiale car
nos agriculteurs aspirent à la
souveraineté ils s'indignent de la
concurrence déloyale de ceux qui ne
respectent pas les mêmes standards de
qualité que nous ils aspirent à
construire notre indépendance agricole
et alimentaire et ils ont raison alors
cet appel avec le président de la
République avec mon gouvernement nous
l'entendons nous y répondons et je sais
qu'il rejoint celui de 68 millions de
Français qui veulent une France plus
forte plus indépendant an plus
souveraine enfin ce cré de colère de nos
agriculteurs est aussi un appel à la
reconnaissance face à ceux qui n'ont eu
de cess ces dernières années de les
traiter comme des pollueurs comme des
bandits comme des bourreaux à ceux qui
en font des bouques émissire facile et
leur prête tous les mots là encore nos
compatriotes se retrouvent dans cette
volonté de reconnaissance ils refusent
de se résigner au déclins que promettent
les fatalistes et les oiseaux de mauvais
augure ils veulent agir défendre notre
identité et défendre la France mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs sous l'égide
du président de la République avec mon
gouvernement avec vous je veux restaurer
cette fierté française je veux répondre
aux inquiétudes de nos compatriotes une
à une sans exception je veux que le
travail paye plus et paye mieux
notamment pour nos concitoyens de classe
moyenne je veux déburaucratiser notre
pays simplifier la vie déverrouiller les
initiatives améliorer le quotidien je
veux porter une souveraineté nationale
et et européenne construire une France
plus juste et plus libre dans une Europe
plus forte je veux que chaque française
que chaque Français puisse être fierè de
son pays que chacun sache qu'il a
pleinement le contrôle de sa vie et que
la France a pleinement son destin en
main cette ambition c'est celle portée
par le Président de la République et les
gouvernements d'Édouard Philippe de Jean
Castex et d'Élisabeth borne depuis 2017
c'est celle que portera mon gouvernement
avec pour seul cap de donner des
résultats pour les Français comme le
veut la coutume républicaine vous avez
entendu hier la lecture de ma
déclaration de politique générale à
l'Assemblée nationale et je remercie
Bruno l maire de l'avoir lu dans ses
moindres
détails je souhaite devant vous revenir
sur les grands combats qui animeront mon
gouvernement vous avez entendu la
lecture de ma déclaration hier je ne
reviendrai pas dans l'ensemble des
détails de ce qui a été abordé à
l'Assemblée nationale hier l'important
est quand même que nous puissions avoir
un échange que je puisse vous entendre
et surtout vous répondre mais je veux
rappeler qu'à l'écoute des Français des
forces politiques des partenaires
sociaux des élus locaux et de nos
concitoyens j'ai pensé et bâti de
première réponse parce que parler au
français c'est d'abord entendre une
exaspération celle je le disais il y a
un instant de ces Français de classe
moyenne trop paisés pour bénéficier des
aides pas assez pour être à l'aise et
qui ne peuvent compter que sur leur
travail c'est français qui demandent que
le travail paye plus et toujours mieux
que l'inactivité parler aux Français
c'est entendre un doute sur nos services
publics sur le respect de l'autorité
dans notre société la crainte du recul
et de l'éloignement pour la santé
l'éducation la sécurité pour toutes les
procédures du quotidien la crainte du
déclin de service publics qui ne serait
plus à la hauteur alors même que l'on
travaille dur et que l'on paye des
impôts pour les financer la crainte
d'une France à deux vitesses où les
classes moyennes et la France modeste
n'auraient plus accès à des services ice
de qualité une France où trop de nos
concitoyens ont le sentiment de ne pas
en avoir pour leurs impôts parler au
français enfin c'est parler de
transition écologique qu'il s'agisse de
jeunes qui s'engagent pour défendre la
planète des habitants du pas decalais
victimes d'inondation pour la deuxème
fois en quelques mois ou des
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontré dans
leurô ou en hautegaron en andrélois tous
ont voulu m'interpeller sur le
déréglement climatique et tous veulent
agir nous partons d'un bilan solide
depuis 2017 sous lesgit du président de
la République nous avons mené des
réformes fortes qui avaient trop attendu
pour libérer le marché du travail nous
en avons mené plusieurs ensemble encore
ces derniers mois je pense notamment à
la réforme de l'assurance chômage ou à
la réforme des retraites aujourd'hui de
premiers résultats arrivent le chômage
est à son niveau le plus bas depuis 25
ans 2 millions d'emplois ont été créés
on crée désormais plus d'emplois
industriel qu'on en supprime dans notre
pays on ouvre plus d'usines qu'on en
ferme dans notre pays évidemment c'est
un début et ça n'efface pas encore des
années de désindustrialisation mais les
premiers résultats les premiers signaux
sont là nous inversons la tendance nous
amplifions notre action sur
l'apprentissage il y avait avant
l'élection du Président de la République
un peu moins de 300000 jeunes en
apprentissage chaque année nous sommes à
850000 jeunes en apprentissage cette
année et nous approchons du million de
jeunes en apprentissage depuis 2017 nous
avons entamé le redressement de nos
services publics nous avons investi des
montants historiques pour le nous avons
engagé des réformes fortes pour notre
éducation et revaloriser les professeurs
nous avons renforcé notre état régalien
avec les investissements sans précédent
pour notre sécurité notre justice et nos
armées nous avons agi aussi pour les
services publics de proximité pour
veiller à ce que chacun y a accès et
nous avons maillé le territoire d'espace
France service ils sont la porte ouverte
aux démarches de nos concitoyens pour
tous où que ce soit enfin le rythme de
nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre a baissé l'année dernière comme il
n'avait jamais baissé dans notre pays en
moyenne nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre baissai d' 1 % par an avant 2017
dans le premier quinquena du président
de la République elles ont baissé de 2 %
par an en moyenne l'an dernier sur les 9
premiers mois de l'année elles ont
baissé de près de 5 %. j'y vois la
preuve que lorsqu'on investit
massivement plutôt que de punir et de
brutaliser nos concitoyens lorsqu'on
investit qu'on accompagne des secteurs
économiques des entreprises et des
industries particulièrement polluantes
qu'on les aide à se décarboner ça
produit des résultats et ça nous permet
d'aller plus vite plus loin que de
chercher à punir à taxer et à brutaliser
cette planification se construira avec
les territoires j'y reviendrai elle
s'adaptera aux défis et aux besoins de
chacun une fois que j'ai dit tout ça je
suis parfaitement lucide sur le fait que
nous n'avons pas réglé tous les
problèmes qu'il reste évidemment des
difficultés dans notre pays qu'il y a
des Français qui souffrent qu'il y a des
Français qui doutent qu'il y a des
Français qui attendent qu'il y a même
des Français qui n'attendent plus rien
parce qu'ils n'y croient plus je suis
conscient du chemin qu'il reste à
parcourir à parcourir pour restaurer la
confiance à parcourir pour arriver à ce
dernier kilomètre qui fait que lorsque
nous annonçons des choses ça puisse se
traduire très concrètement dans le
quotidien des Français et je le dis de
ce point de vue le premier de mes
combats restera celui du travail agir
pour le travail c'est d'abord agir pour
veiller à ce que ceux qui travaillent
gagnent toujours plus que ceux qui ne
travaillent pas agir pour le travail
c'est veiller à ce que l'on gagne mieux
sa vie et offrir des perspectives
d'évolution à chacun c'est aussi
résoudre ce paradoxe qui veut qu'avec un
chômage autour de 7 % il reste des
centaines de milliers d'emplois non
pourvus sur le territoire aussi nous
agirons autour de trois piliers
désmicardisé déverrouillés
débureaucratisé un travail a été entamé
vous le savez pour qu'il n'y ait plus de
branche professionnelle qui rémunère en
dessous du SMIC nous allons le
poursuivre et nous prendrons toutes les
mesures nécessaire pour qu'il puisse
aboutir un très grand travail a été
entamé
ensuite il y a tous ces Français qui
sont
os SMIC ou légèrement au-dessus du SMIC
nous avons ces dernières décennies
concentré les exonérations de cotisation
concentré des dispositifs de soutien
notamment via la prime d'activité autour
du SMIC et la réalité Bruno Le Maire l'a
lu hier dans mon discours c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus beaucoup
d'intérêt pour personne à augmenter le
salaire de salariés proche du SMIC parce
que l'employeur doit payer beaucoup plus
de cotisation sociale parce que le
salarié lui-même perd de sa prime
d'activité voit sa CSG augmenter et bien
souvent entre dans l'impôt sur le revenu
il faut sortir de ce que certains
techniquement appellent ce coin fiscal
au social qui concentre trop de Français
autour du SMIC nous avons un SMIC
supérieur à celui de nos voisins et
c'est une chance mais nous avons
beaucoup plus de salariés qui sont
proche du SMIC que chez les pays voisins
parce que nous avons cette forme de
trappe don dont nous devons sortir des
travaux ont été engagés des propositions
ont été faites par des parlementaires
par un certain nombre d'experts par des
partenaires sociaux je souhaite que dans
les prochains textes financiers nous
amorcions cette évolution je veux
également que nous puissions avancer
s'agissant de la rémunération des
fonctionnaires rendre leur carrière plus
attractive en favorisant l'engagement et
le mérite plutôt que la seule ancienneté
un projet de loi sera présenté en ce
sens dès ce second semestre je veux
avancer pour nos indépendants pour pour
poursuivre la réforme de l'assiette
sociale permettant à des millions
d'artisans de commerçants d'agriculteurs
de professions libéral de acquérir
d'acquérir davantage de droits sociaux
notamment à la retraite sans payer
davantage de cotisation notre deuxième
objectif c'est de déverrouiller le
travail en incitant à l'activité en
accompagnant vers le marché du travail
ceux qui en sont exclus c'est le sens de
l'expérimentation du RSA accompagné de
15 he d'activité pour l'insertion 18
départements étaient concernés ils
seront 40 7 le mois prochain et nous
généraliserons ce dispositif d'ici au
1er janvier 2025 à l'ensemble du
territoire c'est le sens de notre
volonté d'aller plus loin dans la
réforme de l'assurance chômage nous
devons faire preuve de responsabilité
d'audace et d'ambition inciter toujours
plus à la reprise du travail c'est le
sens de notre volonté de supprimer
toutes les trappes à une activité et je
l'assume notamment à l'allocation de
solidarité spécifique qui prolonge les
aides après la fin de l'assurance
chômage qui permet de valider des
trimestres de retraite alors que nous
considérons que la retraite ça doit
toujours être le fruit d'années de
trimestres de travail et non
d'allocation sociale nous la
supprimerons progressivement mais
déverrouiller le travail c'est aussi
faire en sorte que chacun touche ce à
quoi il a droit c'est le sens de la
solidarité à la source nous allons
poursuivre ce chantier déverrouiller le
travail c'est l'adapter aux évolutions
des attentes et des aspirations de nos
concitoyens l'équilibre vie personnelle
vie professionnelle la question des des
horaires des méthodes de management de
télétravail sont autant de défis
auxquels nous devons répondre je
souhaite que l'État soit exemplaire
puisse proposer comme je l'ai fait à
Bery de nouvelles organisations en
expérimentant pour nos agents publics
déverrouiller le travail c'est libérer
notre économie au printemps nous
examinerons un projet de loi en ce sens
je souhaite qu'il puisse permettre de
déverrouiller un certain nombre de
professions comme l'avait fait à
l'époque la fameuse loi Macron enfin
déverrouiller le travail c'est permettre
à chacun d'accéder à un logement car
sans logement abordable il est
impossible d'accéder à un emploi mais
bien plus largement le logement c'est
une des matrice de notre société c'est
la voie ouverte à une vie digne c'est la
confiance trouvée pour beaucoup de
Français de classe moyenne qui voi dans
le fait de bénéficier d'un logement
d'être propriétaire de son logement un
des éléments d'une retraite sereine pour
l'avenir nous voulons avancer pour un
choc d'offre grâce à la simplification
des normes notamment en revoyant les DPE
en simplifiant la densification en
levant certaines contraintes de zonage
grâce à la désignation d'ici quelques
semaines de 20 territoires engagés pour
le logement où les procédures seront
tout accélérés nous y créerons 30000
nouveaux logements d'ici 3 ans nous
créerons ce choc d'offre en assumant de
réquisitionner des bâtiments vide
notamment des bâtiments de bureau nous
le créerons en soutenant le logement
social grâce à un nouveau prêt de long
terme pour acheter du foncier 2
milliards d'euros distribués par la
banque des territoires évidemment ce que
je propose ici n'est qu'un début
pour continuer à bâtir à construire
continuer à permettre à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de devenir propriétaire nous
irons plus loin plus loin pour soutenir
la construction plus loin pour soutenir
les Français qui veulent devenir ou
rester propriétaires plus loin pour
loger un certain nombre d'agents publics
qui assure notamment notre sécurité
notre santé et l'éducation de nos
enfants qui doivent avoir une forme de
priorité dans l'accès à un certain
nombre de logements sociaux plus loin
pour faire du logement des Français un
facteur de bien-être pour tous et pour
Chac
alors nous allons proposer de faire
évoluer la loi SRU en répondant ainsi à
des attentes anciennes et récurrentes
des élus locaux d'une part les maires
auront enfin la main pour la première
attribution des logements sociaux dans
leur
[Applaudissements]
communes d'autre part nous proposons que
les logements intermédiaires accessible
à la classe moyenne soit désormais
inclus dans le calcul de la part de
logement social dans le cadre de la loi
SRU je veux le dire aussi clairement à
ceux qui s'inquiètent dans les communes
soumises à la loi nous maintiendrons
évidemment une exigence d'un nombre
minimal de logements très sociaux enfin
à la veille des 70 ans de l'appel de
l'abbé Pierre je veux rappeler ici
l'engagement de mon gouvernement à
lutter contre le mal
logement un logement digne c'est le
fondement d'une vie digne nous y
travaillerons
une proposition de loi pour lutter
contre lescopropriété dégradé a été
adoptée à la quasi unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale je suis sûr que
nous pouvons travailler ensemble au
Sénat pour faire avancer ce combat nous
y travaillerons en continuant à soutenir
l'hébergement d'urgence je rappelle à
ceux qui nous interpellent que lorsque
le président de la République a été élu
en 2017 il y avait à peine une centaine
de milliers de logement dans les de
places dans l'hébergement d'urgence nous
avons doublé les places dans
l'hébergement d'urgence nous sommes
aujourd'hui
n nons pas de le
àoir Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatri
sénateur notre 3è
priorité à l'Assemblée nationale il son
all très fort j'ai quand même déroulé
mon discours je le dérouler ici même si
on
m'interpelle justement vous écter
monsieur Premier ministre notreè
priorité c'est de déburaucratiser la
société les agriculteurs les élus locaux
les entrepreneurs les indépendants et
les artisans comme tous ceux qui créent
de l'emploi sur notre sol comme tous
ceux qui agissent nous le disent il y a
trop de règles trop de normes trop de
procédures qui les brim et parfois
brisent leurs initiatives alors face à
la bureaucratisation il y a une réponse
simple elle s'appelle la simplification
à l'automne nous engagerons une nouvelle
étape de la réforme du droit du travail
pour simplifier la vie de nos
entrepreneurs le quotidien de nos PME et
de nos TPE nous allons également
simplifier nos procédures pour amplifier
encore la réindustrialisation nous avons
beaucoup avancé avec la loi industrie
verte mais il faut aller plus loin il
n'est pas normal qu'il faille deux fois
plus de temps pour sortir un projet
industriel en France qu'en Allemagne
cela limite nos possibilités
d'investissement étranger sur notre pays
une fois qu'on a dit ça monsieur le
rapporteur général Husson on prend un
certain nombre de mesures pour continuer
à réduire les délais comme nous l'avons
fait dans la loi industrie verte nous
présenterons une deuxème loin industrie
verte pour aller encore plus loin j'ai
donné une première piste hier à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment sans
centrer le travail de la CNDP sur les
très grands projets d'envergure
nationale pour libérer un grand nombre
de projets de la procédure de la CNDP ce
qui fera gagner 6 mois dans certaines
procédures pour avancer la
déburaucratisation doit toucher tous les
secteurs aujourd'hui chaque Français
dans ses démarches dans son activité
peut mesurer combien notre pays est
à quel point nous pourrions faire
mieux et plus vite tous les sujets sont
sur la table pour simplifier accélérer
faciliter la vie des français et je le
dis ici
ce travail de
débureaucratisation nous le ferons en
premier lieu avec les maires parce que
les maires sont très concernés dans leur
vie quotidienne dans leur action
quotidienne en tant qu'élus mais ils
sont aussi des témoins de toutes ces
complexités parce que bien souvent des
Français des entrepreneurs des
agriculteurs qui font face à ces
complexités dans les normes dans les
procédures ils viennent avant tout en
parler à leur MRE les maires je crois
sont les plus lucides ceux qui ont la
vision la plus exhaustive de toutes ces
cont de tous ces freins dans la vie de
nos concitoyens c'est donc avec eux que
nous construirons des solutions pour
eux-mêmes pour les élus mais aussi pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et ils
seront je crois aussi des porvoies de
nos concitoyens nous allons
déverrouiller dmicardiser
débureaucratiser dans un seul objectif
réarmer notre pays assurer sa
souveraineté permettre à chacun d'avoir
son destin en main pour cela et je sais
combien vous y êtes attentif nous devons
faire preuve d'uneons budgétaire absolue
la dette publique est une épée de
damoclesè au-dessus de notre modèle
social au-dessus de la capacité à agir
des jeunes générations c'est une menace
majeure pour nos classes moyennes qui
sera les premières victimes d'une cure
massive d'austérité et d'augmentation
brutale d'impôt aussi grâce à l'activité
au travail grâce à la maîtrise des
dépenses grâce à des réformes
structurelles nous allons tenir notre
cap qui doit nous conduire à repasser
sous les 3 % de déficit d'ici i
2027 nous le ferons sans augmenter les
impôts nous le ferons en menant une
revue de dépenses ambitieuse qui
concernera tous les ministères des
premières mesures d'économie seront
annoncées fin mars et nous y
travaillerons ensemble en vue du PLF je
souhaite que la représentation nationale
dans son ensemble puisse se saisir très
en amont du PLF de ces propositions
d'économie et que nous puissions
travailler échanger ensemble avant la
discussion du PLF nous atteindrons aussi
nos objectif en renforçant encore notre
lutte contre la fraude qu'elle soit
fiscale sociale ou douanière vous savez
combien j'y suis attentif je regarde la
sénatrice Goulet mais beaucoup d'entre
vous sont très mobilisés sur cette
question Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs grâce à ces
réformes grâce à l'activité au travail
nous allons pouvoir continuer à réarmer
nos services publics faire en sorte que
tous les Français en soient fiers je
pense à notre système de santé nous
devons aller plus vite et plus fort nous
le devons à nos soignants c'est grâce à
leur engagement sans faille que le
système tient et je veux leur rendre
hommage alors je ne me paye pas de mots
je sais que les soignants comme les
patients attendent des actes et avec le
gouvernement nous allons continuer à
agir nous devons d'abord faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus de médecins et plus de
soignants dans notre pays c'est le sens
de la suppression du numérus closus
mesure structurante mais dont les effets
d'abord ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement et qui doit probablement
être forcer pour que nous puissions
former encore davantage de médecins je
ne me résoudrai jamais à ce que des
jeunes Français qui veulent devenir
médecins qui travaillent pour devenir
médecin doivent partir à l'étranger à
l'est de l'Europe ou ailleurs pour faire
leurs études de
médecine pour agir rapidement évidemment
parce que nous avons aussi besoin de
médecin tout de suite et que cela prend
un certain temps de former des médecins
nous allons régulariser les médecins
étrangers sur notre territoire c'est un
engagement du Président de la République
nous allons aussi permettre au soignants
qui exercent des années d'avoir des
passerelles effectives et efficaces pour
les études de médecine j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire hier à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est une proposition qui
émane d'ailleurs du député Neer du
groupe LR à l'Assemblée nationale une
infirmière anesthésiste qui a un bac + 5
qui a plusieurs années d'expérience elle
doit pouvoir rentrer au moins en 3e
année de médecine si elle le souhaite
pour devenir médecin et exercer dans les
années à venir dans notre
pays pour agir rapidement nous allons
aussi libérer davantage de temps médical
nous doublerons le nombre d'assistants
médicaux nous allons assumer de dire que
quand on a un rendez-vous chez le
médecin qu'on ne s'y présente pas sans
prévenir quel que soit son statut quelle
que soit sa couverture on paye sa
consultation c'est une question d'accès
aux soins chaque année ce sont des
millions de consultations qui ne peuvent
pas être assurées parce qu' avaient été
prévus et que les patients ne se sont
pas présentés les médecins nous le
disent les Français qui n'ont pas accès
à des consultations suffisamment tôt
nous le disent il faut responsabiliser
de ce point de vue là assumer que les
droits et devoirs c'est pour tout le
monde je m'y engage également nous
allons continuer à lutter contre les
déserts médicaux c'est une angoisse de
nos concitoyens notamment dans la
ruralité dans les petites villes ou dans
les villes moyennes c'est une
préoccupation forte du Sénat je le sais
et je sais combien vous en faites le
relais c'est une priorité d'action de
mon gouvernement depuis 2017 nous avons
déployé le service d'accès aux soins le
sas qui permet d'améliorer l'accès à la
santé j'étais à Dijon il y a encore
quelques jours avec certains d'entre
vous nous avons vu à quel point ce
système fonctionne et permet de mieux
orienter des patients sur du non
programmé et donc de de de désengorger
les urgences et de permettre à des
patients d'être pris en charge en ville
quand c'est ce qui est nécessaire d'ici
à à l'été je souhaite que chaque
département soit doté d'un service
d'accès aux soins et si ce n'est pas le
cas si les réponses sont toujours
insuffisante je n'ai pas de tabou et des
obligations de garde pour les médecins
libéraux pourrai être décidé enfin je
veux avoir un mot de la santé de nos
jeunes du travail exceptionnel mené par
les infirmières scolaires pour détecter
conseiller soigner nous avons besoin de
plus d'infirmières scolaires nous
voulons rendre leur métier plus
attractif aussi nous leur verserons une
prime exceptionnel de 800 € au mois de
mai et à partir de cette date toutes les
infirmières scolaires de France à partir
du mois de mai seront payé 200 € net de
plus par mois en moyenne c'est juste et
c'est nécessaire nous avancerons aussi
pour déployer des maisons des
adolescents dans tous les territoires
pour revaloriser également et revoir
complètement le dispositif mon soutien
PSI pour que des jeunes des jeunes qui
sont en dépression des jeunes qui ont un
malêtre des jeunes qui ont des pensées
suicidaires pu puisse accéder à une
prise en charge par un psychologue
beaucoup plus rapidement je sais que le
Sénat là aussi s'était engagé je regarde
la sénatrice de lâre qui avait beaucoup
travailler sur ce sujet mais vous n vous
n'êtes pas la seule et d'autres en
avaient
parlé je parle des sénateurs mais tous
les sénateurs s'engagent j'aurais pu
citer sur la santé la sénatrice
chilinger et d'autres ici se sont
engagés le réarmement de nos services
publics c'est le réarmement de notre
école aujourd'hui les parents
s'inquiètent du niveau scolaire et les
enseignants ont le sentiment de ne plus
avoir les moyens de faire progresser
leurs élèves la réponse ça doit d'abord
être le choc des savoir c'est faire en
sorte que l'école ne soit pas un
escalator qui permettrait de passer de
classe en classe automatiquement sans
avoir à faire d'effort sans que personne
ne regarde si on a le niveau suffisant
pour réussir dans la classe
supérieure
c'est pourquoi nous assumerons et le
texte sera pris dans les toutes
prochaines semaines de redonner le
dernier mot sur la décision du
redoublement à l'équipe pédagogique et
non plus à la famille il n'y a personne
de mieux qu'un enseignant pour savoir le
niveau d'un élève et sa capacité à
réussir dans la classe supérieure nous
assumerons également de relever le
niveau du brevet des collèges nous avons
dit et nous le tiendrons que dès cette
année nous supprimerons le correctif
académique qui conduisait depuis des
années à gonfler artificiellement les
notes de nos élèves au brevet dans
beaucoup de territoires pour atteindre
un certain niveau un certain taux de
réussite pour faire plaisir à tout le
monde mentir à nos élèves sur leurs
notes mentir aux familles sur le niveau
de leurs enfants c'est ne pas répondre à
l'objectif et à la nécessité de
l'exigence que nous avons pour nos
élèves et à la fin c'est ne pas
respecter notre objectif d'égalité des
chances un diplôme sans conséquence
c'est un diplôme qui n'a pas de sens
nous réhausserons le niveau du brevet
pour apprendre chacun doit pouvoir aller
à son rythme c'est le sens des groupes
de niveau qui se mettront en place au
collège dès la rentrée prochaine en
français et en mathématiques un
enseignant en français qui a dans sa
classe des élèves qui ne savent pas lire
avec des élèves qui savent très bien
lire ils n'arrivent plus à faire
progresser personne nous assumerons ces
groupes de niveau en français et en
mathématiqu pour apprendre les élèves ne
doivent pas être distraits et obnubilés
par les écrans lesc sont une catastrophe
éducative et sanitaire en puissance
alors nous avons banni les téléphones
portables au collège et conformément à
l'engagement du président de la
République n nous déploierons de
nouvelles mesures pour mieux réguler
l'usage des écrans à l'école et en
dehors de l'école j'ajoute que pour
apprendre nos élèves doient avoir des
enseignants devant eux nous avons déjà
multiplié par 3 la part d' remplacé mais
nous n'y sommes pas encore nous
évaluerons les effets du PACT enseignant
et nous en tirerons toutes les leçons
pour réarmer notre nos élèves ont besoin
d'être heureux c'est pour leur bien-être
que nous luttons pied à pied sans
relâche contre le harcèlement scolaire
je sais que c'est un sujet pour lequel
là aussi beaucoup se sont engagés sur
ces bancs c'est un défi qui me tient à
cœur je suis fier d'avoir lancé une
nouvelle stratégie contre le harcèlement
fier que ce soit désormais à l'élève
harceleur de quitter l'établissement et
non plus à l'élève
harcelés c'est pour le bien-être de les
élèves que nous bâtissons une société
inclusive pour une école inclusive pour
nos enfants en situation de handicap
l'état prendra désormais en charge le
salaire des aesh sur la pause de midi
c'était une proposition de loi portée
par le sénateur Vial et nous la
soutiendront nous mettons fin ainsi à
des années de querell entre les
collectivités locales et l'État au
détriment des élèves en situation de
handicap et de ceux qui les aident si je
parle des élèves de nos écoles je veux
aussi avoir un mot pour les étudiantes
et les étudiants de notre pays nous
continuerons à agir pour eux pour notre
enseignement supérieur à le tourner vers
des filières d'avenir pourvoyeuses de
sens et d'emploi nous continuerons à
agir pour celles et ceux qui pour qui
étudier demandent des sacrific et qui
sont les plus en difficulté alors nous
avons maintenu le repas à 1 € cru pour
les étudiants boursiers et pour les
étudiants non boursiers qui en auraiit
besoin et nous menons une réforme des
bourses qui a déjà permis de toucher
plus d'étudiants et revaloriser les
bourses jusqu'à 127 € supplémentaires
par mois dans l'Hexagone et jusqu'à 157
€ supplémentaires par mois pour les
étudiants dans les outresmers Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
le réarmement de l'école sera vain si
nos valeurs ne sont pas respectées si
l'autorité n'y est pas respectée comme
ministre j'ai toujours été du côté de
nos professeurs comme chef du
gouvernement je le reste et je le
resterai l'autorité c'est respecter les
professeurs et nos valeurs républicaines
la relation entre un professeur et son
élève n'est pas une relation d'égal à
égal il y a celui qui sait il y a celui
qui apprend celui qui sait à l'autorité
sur celui qui apprend parce que celui
qui sait à l'autorité du savoir qui lui
est conféré par sa mission et par ses
années de
formation l'autorité c'est donc
respecter les professeurs et nos valeurs
républicaines c'est pouvoir enseigner
tout le programme sans exception et
avoir une échelle de sanction adapté
pour les élèves qui ne l'accepteraient
pas c'est veiller à ce que tous les
élèves respectent nos valeurs
républicaines la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité et au sein d'elle évidemment
la laïcité fondement même de l'école de
la République pour que nous devons
continuer à défendre comme nous l'avons
fait en assumant d'interdire la BAA dans
tous les établissements scolaires de
notre
pays c'est aussi l'autorité et
l'autorité des valeurs de la République
à prendre partout les paroles de la
Marseillaise
doubler le nombre d'heures d'instruction
civique dès le collège l'autorité c'est
à l'école c'est aussi dans la famille
lors des émeutes de juillet la France a
été frappée par le choc elle a aussi été
sidérée par la jeunesse des émeutiers
des jeunes de moins de 15 ans parfois de
moins de 13 ans des jeunes qui n'ont
plus de repère pour qui la violence est
parfois devenue un passtemp ces jeunes
nous devons
pouvoir les accompagner nous devons
aussi pouvoir mieux les sanction
avec des peines adaptées aujourd'hui il
est impossible de prononcer une peine de
travaux d'intérêt général en dessous de
16 ans alors nous créerons les travaux
d'intérêt éducatifs qui pourront être
prononcés y compris pour les jeunes de
moins de 16 ans nous viendrons en appui
des famille qui n'y arrivent plus de ces
mères parfois seules qui doivent élever
plusieurs enfants et sont parfois
impuissantes face à la dérive et au
mauvaise fréquentation de certains nous
proposerons sur simple demande des
parents que les jeunes à la dérive
puisse être placé en internat nous avons
aujourd'hui 50000 places d'internat qui
sont vacantes dans notre pays ces places
doivent servir à accueillir des jeunes
qui en ont besoin enfin nous devons
aussi responsabiliser les parents des
jeunes délinquants qui se seraient
volontairement soustrait à leur
responsabilité parentale il pourrai
désormais être condamnés à des travaux
d'intérêt général là aussi nous
avancerons l'autorité c'est également
dans la rue la délinquance mine la
confiance dans le pacte républicain
beaucoup a été fait grâce à des moyens
inédits mais nous devons aussi revoir
notre stratégie nous devons veiller à la
sécurité de tous partout sur le
territoire y compris dans notre ruralité
c'est pourquoi nous installerons 238
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie nous
allons amplifier encore la lutte contre
la drogue qui est la matrice de tous les
VI nous continuerons notre stratégie de
pilonnage des points de deal qui montre
de premiers résultats avec déjà un/art
des points de deal qui ont été supprimés
nous lancerons un nouveau plan de lutte
contre les stupéfiants avec notamment
une mesure forte taper les trafiquants
au porte-monnaie en gelant leurs avoir
nous voulons également agir contre la
délinquance du quotidien nous aurons une
attention particulière à la lutte contre
les cambriolages enfin pour être
efficace nous avons besoin d'une réponse
pénale à la hauteur nous voulons une
justice plus rapide et plus efficace
nous lui en donnons les moyens vous le
savez avec une augmentation historique
de son budget mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs alors que j'évoque le défi des
services publics je pense bien entendu à
nos territoires d'outrem les outr-emers
sont une chance immense pour la France
ce sont aussi des terres où tous les
défis semblent se concentrer le défi de
la vie chè auquel nous devons répondre
le défi de l'emploi alors que le chômage
est plus élevé que dans l'Hexagone le
défi de la santé de l'école de la
sécurité de la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale de la transition
écologique alors nous allons continuer à
agir pour nos outrmè continuer à prendre
des mesures concrètes pour améliorer le
quotidien de nos concitoyens ultramarins
nous devrons notamment répondre aux
singularités et aux défis de maotte avec
un projet de loi spécifique sur le
territoire enfin il existe un lien
particulier entre l'hôtel de Matignon et
la Nouvelle Calédonie un lien comme un
écho au dialogue à l'espoir de paix et
de construction de l'avenir par TR par
trois fois la Nouvelle-Calédonie a
choisi la République il faut maintenant
que les échanges en cours et le
processus politique aboutisse j'y serai
attentif et vous examinerez dans
quelques semaines un projet de loi
constitutionnel sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs le
3è combat de mon gouvernement c'est la
transition écologique ces derniers mois
nous nous sommes dotés d'un plan unique
au monde la planification écologique
grâce à elle nous avons une feuille de
route précise secteur par secteur pour
baisser nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 55 % d'ici 2030 pour nous
adapter aux changement inévitables pour
le climat pour restaurer notre
biodiversité et préserver nos ressources
ces objectifs nous y tenons nous les
atteindrons le préalable c'est de faire
bloc de ne pas mener la transition
écologique seulement avec les uns et
contre les autres nous voulons faire la
transition avec le peuple et avec les
élus sans brutalité sans invective sans
décroissance nous ne voulons pas montrer
du doigt pointer du doigt mais au
contraire rassembler toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont conscience de la
nécessité d'agir nous serons toujours
les porteurs d'une écologie des
solutions qui offre des alternatives et
des réponses à ceux qui ont peur de la
transition écologique je ne prendrai
qu'un exemple les transports mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs vous savez mieux
que personne combien il est impossible
de priver nos concitoyens de leur
voiture dans la ruralité dans les
petites villes dans les villes moyennes
les privés de voiture ce serait les
privés de travail les privés de loisirs
les privés de vie sociale alors plutôt
que les privations nous proposons des
solutions c'est le sens de l'offre de
location de véhicules électriques pour
moins de 100 € par mois cette offre est
lancée et elle est un succès c'est aussi
la raison pour laquelle nous proposons
de renforcer de soutenir les
alternatives là où c'est possible ça
n'est pas possible partout c'est ce que
je disais il y a un instant et vous le
savez sur les transports au commun
notamment au niveau métropolitain et
régional nous allons continuer à agir
les engagements du Président de la
République sur le ferroviaire seront
tenus la clé de réussite de notre
transition écologique c'est sa capacité
à s'encrer dans les territoires les
territoires ne nous ont pas attendu pour
agir les concertations se sont
intensifié depuis quelques mois avec le
lancement des cops territoriales qui
rassemblent les élus locaux à tous les
échel
territoire par territoire c'est ensemble
avec les élus que nous pourrons mener
les meilleurs diagnostics sur les enjeux
de chaque territoire c'est ensemble avec
les élus que nous pourrons bâtir les
solutions les plus adaptées c'est
ensemble que nous pourrons disposer des
financements adapté l'État sera au
rendez-vous et je souhaite que les plans
locaux de financement de la transition
écologique soi tous conclus pour cet été
enfin cet ensemble que nous pourrons
bâtir la résilience des territoires face
au dérèglement climatiques en prononçant
ces mots je pense notamment aux victimes
des inondations dans le pas decalais
c'est auprès d'eux que j'ai fait mon
premier déplacement en tant que Premier
ministre comme je m'y étais engagé j'y
retournerai très prochainement auprès
des victimes des inondations pour faire
un point sur la reconstruction sur le
déblocage des aides d'urgence mais aussi
pour préparer l'avenir la transition
écologique c'est aussi réussir la
transition énergétique là encore je sais
que ce sujet importe particulièrement au
Sénat notre stratégie repose sur trois
piliers la sobriété le nucléaire et le
ouvable c'est grâce à cet équilibre que
nous pouvons conquérir notre
indépendance énergétique garantir des
prix bas et une énergie décarbonée au
français je veux le dire ici clairement
comme je l'ai fait hier à l'Assemblée
nationale nous assumons pleinement le
choix du nucléaire nous le soutenons
nous développons de nouveaux programmes
et 2024 sera une grande année pour le
nucléaire français avec la mise en
service de le Pr de
flamville enfin pour mener le combat de
l'écologie à la française nous devons
aussi
poursuivre nous devons aussi poursuivre
notre réarmement agricole protéger notre
exception agricole française c'est mon
engagement c'est le combat du
gouvernement depuis 2017 avec les plans
de filière avec les lois égalim avec
l'assurance récolte avec le varen de
l'eau ce sont les positions de la France
au niveau européen pour protéger nos
agriculteurs et se battre pour des me
pour des meilleures mesures et pour des
clauses miroires aider nos agriculteurs
à produire plus en les libérant des
démarches administratives qui les
éloignent de leur bêtes et de leur champ
les aider à produire plus car c'est la
clé de notre indépendance alimentaire
nous devons aussi continuer à les
protéger que ce soit contre les crises
et nous le faisons systématiquement
depuis 7 ans ou bien contre la
concurrence desloyales de ceux qui n'ont
pas les mêmes standards que nous et dont
les produits arrivent pourtant en France
les crises de ces dernières semaines
mouvement plôt des dernières semaines
vient de très loin la situation ne peut
se régler tout de suite ce serait un
songe que de le dire ce qui est vrai en
revanche c'est que nous sommes
déterminés à changer les choses avec nos
agriculteurs dès la semaine dernière
j'ai annoncé de premières réponses pour
une juste rémunération des agriculteurs
avec un renforcement des contrôles dans
le cadre des négociations commerciales
pour la simplification avec 10 normes
très concrètes qui seront simplifiées
dans les T prochains jours et j'ajoute
que partout en France j'ai demandé au
préfet de réunir les représentants des
agriculteurs dans chaque département le
premier département qui a commencer ce
travail c'est la HauteGaronne en
quelques réunions sur une semaine quatre
arrêtés préfectoraux ont été abrogés
dans le département de HauteGaronne ça
montre que cette mesure fonctionne et
que cette méthode fonctionne j'ai
demandé qu'elle soit dès cette semaine
dupliquée sur l'ensemble du territoire
des réponses rapides pour la trésorerie
des exploitants avec l'annulation de la
hausse de la taxe sur le GNR agricole
avec l'engagement que les aides de la
PAC arrivrive avant le 15 mars des
réponses rapides face aux crises enfin
avec l'ouverture lundi prochain du
guichet de prise en charge du fond
vétérinaire pour la MHE ou encore avec
le doublement du fond d'urgence pour la
Bretagne évidemment il reste à faire
avec mon gouvernement nous sommes
pleinement
mobilisés nous avons avancé encore ces
derniers jours avec les agriculteurs
avec leurs représentants avanthier soir
hier soir ce matin encore avec j'étais
avec les représentants des agriculteurs
nous allons continuer à le faire
notamment à le faire pourc favoriser
l'installation et la transmission des
exploitations pour un meilleur
renouvellement des générations je ne
crois pas à la crise des vocations en
agriculture il y a beaucoup de jeunes
qui veulent s'engager en agriculture et
des moins jeunes d'ailleurs qui parfois
veulent aussi se reconvertir et
s'engager pour l'agriculture c'est une
crise de l'attractivité il faut lever
tous les freins qui font que ces
vocations sont parfois bridées nous
avancerons sur ce terrain il faut
continuer à avancer sur la question du
revenu et notamment sur l'application
des lois égalis je rappelle quand même
qu' avant la loi égalim c'était la loi
LME de 2009 qui s'appliquait qui donnait
les pleins pouvoirs à la grande
distribution et que la loi égalim a
constitué à ce titre un progrès je n'ai
rencontré aucun agriculteur à ce stade
qui m'a demandé de revenir à la
situation pré égalime au contraire il
nous demande qu'galim soit mieux
appliqué et que sur un certain nombre de
points elle elle soit corrigé c'est
l'objet de nos travaux et de nos
discussions en ce moment nous
continuerons à avancer sur la
simplification avec de nouvelles mesures
pour simplifier le quotidien très
concrètement nous continuerons à avancer
sur la relation entre les agriculteurs
et un certain nombre de services de
l'État notamment l'ofb j'ai annoncé de
premières mesures vendredi nous allons
continuer à le faire nous allons
continuer à avancer avec eux sur la
concurrence équitable en renforçant les
contrôles sur les produits les choses
sont simples un produit qui rentre en
France doit avoir les mêmes standards de
qualité qu'un produit cultivé en France
sinon ça s'appelle de la concurrence
déloyales et nous sommes des déterminé à
la combattre et je rappelle je rappelle
que c'est cette majorité notre majorité
et d'ailleurs je crois que la majorité
sénatoriale l'avait soutenu qui a qui a
assumé de réautoriser l'utilisation des
nicotinoïdes pour la production de la
betterave après l'annulation qui était
intervenue sous le quinquen de François
Hollande une une interdiction sans
aucune solution si nous n'avions pas
pris cette décision il n'y aura plus de
filiè betrave nous avons assumé de le
faire et nous avons assumé de tenir le
pas interdiction sans solution depuis
2017 enfin nous agissons au niveau
européen nous nous sommes fixés trois
priorités les importation ukrainiennees
les négociations mercosour et les jaers
trois priorités immédiates le président
de la République s'est mobilisé sur
chacun de ces sujets dès ce matin un
paquet de mesures a été adopté par la
commission qu'il s'agisse de la
dérogation sur les sur les jachè et je
rappelle que ça fait des mois que la
France est mobilisée nous avons réuni
autour de nous une coalition de 22 États
qui nous per permett aujourd'hui
d'obtenir cette mesure il s'agit de la
mise en place de mécanisme de sauvegarde
sur les importations ukrainiennes
notamment sur les volailles les œufs et
le sucre les choses avancent des
annonces ont été faites ce matin parce
que nous nous battons enfin s'agissant
du mercosour la position de la France
est claire le compte n'y est pas et les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour sa
conclusion nous avons bloqué sa
conclusion j'ajoute que j'aurais un
principe clair appliquer le droit
européen mais rien de plus
je prendrai des mesures pour éviter
toute
surtransposition ce n'est évidemment pas
tout et je le dis je l'ai dit à instant
nous allons aller plus loin j'étais
encore ce matin avec les représentant
des agriculteurs des contacts sont
encore prévus dans les prochaines heures
je sais que vous l'êtes aussi Mesdames
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
et j'aurai très prochainement dans les
tous prochains jours à faire des
annonces à la suite de ce travail que
nous menons ensemble monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je vous parle de
souveraineté je veux aussi dire que je
verrai au souveraineté au respect de
notre souveraineté nationale une
souveraineté nationale portée par des
armées remarquables dont nous aurons
doubler le budget en deux quinquenin ce
sont des moyens sans précédent comme le
prévoit la loi de programmation
militaire nous respecterons nos
engagements et je tiens ici avec vous à
rendre hommage à tous nos militaires qui
défendent et protègent la France et nos
valeurs je veux aussi m'incliner avec
respect devant la mémoire de ceux qui
sont tombés en servant notre pays notre
souveraineté nationale c'est aussi le
respect de nos frontières hier j'ai posé
un principe simple accueillir moins pour
accueillir mieux je m'y tiens grâce à la
loi immigration nous avons renforcé
notre droit grâce au pacte asile
immigration décidé au niveau européen
nous sommes enfin en capacité de décider
qui entre dans Schengen ou
non et grâce à la réforme à venir de
l'aide médicale d'État comme s'y est
engagé ma prédécesseur sur la base des
recommandations du rapport evvin
stéphanini nous serons rapidement en
mesure d'avancer là aussi enfin notre
souveraineté nationale c'est encore
notre souveraineté européenne nous
entrons dans une année cruciale pour
l'Europe une année où il faudra dire
stop ou encore une année où il faudra
choisir entre la faiblesse de
l'isolement et la force du collectif
depuis 2017 l'Europe s'est prise en main
elle est devenue plus forte plus
politique elle apporte des améliorations
concrètes dans la vie de nos concitoyens
je pense au vaccin contre le covid au
moyens pour le plan de relance au
soutien à notre industrie elle nous
permet également d'aborder certains
grands défis avec plus de force et de
puissance je pense à la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique ou encore aux
avancées que nous avons obtenu face aux
géants du numérique ou aux
multinationales qui font de
l'optimisation fiscale monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs assumer notre souveraineté
c'est aussi défendre résolument nos
valeurs et chercher toujours de nouveaux
progrès nos valeurs c'est notre
exception culturelle notre patri
patrimoine est le symbole de notre
histoire nous devons le préserver et le
mettre toujours en avant notre création
fait notre rayonnement et notre fierté
nous devons la soutenir nous devons la
rendre plus accessible à tous notamment
dans la ruralité et de premières
initiatives ont été lancées par le
gouvernement ces derniers jours nos
valeurs c'est l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes c'est le sens du futur
congé de naissance mieux rémunéré et que
les parents pourront se répartir alors
que le congé parental lui éloignait
durablement les femmes de l'emploi nos
valeurs c'est affirmé le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps hier
dans un vote qui a dépassé l'éclivage
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un projet
de loi constitutionnel pour inscrire la
liberté de recourir à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution alors que les droits des
femmes sont toujours les premiers
remises en cause je suis intimement
convaincu qu'inscrire cette liberté dans
la Constitution est une protection
nécessaire vous avez déjà réussi à
travailler ensemble Assemblée nationale
et Sénat autour d'une rédaction commune
je suis sûr que vous y qui parviendrait
à nouveau enfin nos valeurs c'est
permettre à chacun de mourir dans la
dignité la fin de vie relève de l'intime
c'est une question qui renvoie à sa
propre histoire à ses propres
convictions à ce que l'on a vécu à ce
que l'on a vu aujourd'hui le constat de
beaucoup de malades de beaucoup de
familles de beaucoup de Français et
pressants devont entendre leur appel à y
répondre avec vous avec gravité prudence
et dans le respect des convictions de
chacune et de chacun nous le ferons
d'une part nous déploierons davantage
d'unités de soins palliatifs il en faut
une par département au moins ensuite
nous examinerons avant l'été un projet
de loi sur l'aide active à mourir
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs pour chacune de
nos politiques publiques sans exception
nous agirons main dans la main avec les
élus locaux à l'écoute de leurs
préoccupations de leurs alertes et de
leurs attentes élu local c'est un mandat
que je connais à mon niveau je ne suis
qu'un conseiller municipal d'opposition
dans dans sa commune depuis près une
dizaine d'années déjà une dizaine
d'années mais je sais à quel point je le
vois dans ma ville de vant je le vois à
chaque fois que je me déplace je sais à
quel point leur engagement est absolu et
lu local c'est le plus beau des
engagements c'est se battre pour des
projets les bâtir et les voir grandir
c'est se battre pour ses concitoyens et
prendre des décisions concrètes qui
changent réellement le quotidien c'est
se battre pour un territoire une
parcelle de notre pays qui détient une
part de son histoire et de son identité
être élu local c'est répondre à nos
concitoyens tous les jours sans
exception c'est agir pour eux croire en
eux être prêt à déplacer les montagnes
pour eux tous les jours sans exception
avec vous je veux rendre hommage à tous
les élus locaux de France les remercier
leur dire ma gratitude ma confiance
celle de mon gouvernement leur dire ma
détermination aussi est celle de mon
gouvernement à construire l'avenir avec
eux à leur faciliter la vie leur mandat
et leur mission nous sommes prêts à
avancer ensemble prêt à accélérer avec
les territoires qui le souhaitent sur
les sujets qu'il désire prêt à
expérimenter à différencier à adapter
nos règles mais pour réussir il faut que
les choses soient claires je sais que
les élus locaux et vous avec demandent
des clarifications sur les compétences
sur le statut des élus sur le
financement des
collectivités reconnaissons-le les
compétences des uns et des autres sont
dans un véritable casse-tête elles
s'enchevêtrre c'est inefficace dans
notre action publique c'est dangereux
démocratiquement car beaucoup de nos
concitoyens ne savent plus vers qui se
tourner ne savent plus qui est
responsable de quoi et sont souvent
perdus déçus et sans réponse c'est le
cocktail parfait pour nourrir la
défiance et la colère autant dire le
cocktail parfait pour faire le lit des
populistes alors là aussi la France a
besoin d'une clarification et d'une
simplification forte c'est tout l'enjeu
de la mission confiée au député Eric par
le Président de la République sur la
clarification des compétences des
collectivités Eric vert évidemment dans
son travail j'ai échangé avec lui sur
l'état d'avancement de sa mission a
beaucoup consulté vous avez été un
certain nombre évidemment à le
rencontrer à le voir évidemment il
s'appuie aussi sur un certain nombre de
travaux qui avaient été conduits
notamment ici au Sénat beaucoup de
missions de rapports j'en suis convaincu
ont été commis ont été proposés l'enjeu
désormais c'est d'avancer et d'avancer
vite vers cette clarif vers cette
clarification des compétences Eric vert
nous rendra ses premières conclusions
d'ici au printemps notre objectif est
simple dépasser les débats stériles sur
l'échelon à conserver ou supprimer et
nous concentrer sur les moyens
d'améliorer vraiment l'action publique
locale la règle doit être simple pour
une compétence il faut un responsable et
un financement dédié et je souhaite
qu'une loi construite avec les
associations d'élus soit présentée avant
la fin de l'année 2024 pour tirer les
conclusions de la mission d'Eric vert et
des travaux qui ont été conduits dans
cette chambre et à l'Assemblée nationale
dès maintenant l'État prend sa part dans
cet effort de simplification d'une part
nous simplifierons drastiquement les
normes applicables aux collectivités
pour redonner du pouvoir d'agir aux élus
locaux cela passera notamment par une
réforme du droit de dérogation nous
voulons casser les carcans qui brident
les initiatives des élus locaux d'autre
part je veux réaffirmer un principe
simple le préfet doit avoir autorité sur
les opérateurs de son département pour
mieux coordonner leur
action sur tous ces sujets je souhaite
de premiers résultats et des décisions
fortes dans les 6 mois j'y veillai en
lien étroit avec les préfets permettre
aux élus d'accomplir pleinement leur
mission c'est aussi leur donner les
marche de manœuvre dont ils ont besoin
nous avons beaucoup fait notamment d'un
point de vue financier je le rappelle
nous avons tenu nos engagements
vis-à-vis des collectivités dans les de
deux derniers PLF pour la première fois
depuis 13 ans la DGF a augmenté ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 13 ans ça
n'était pas arrivé depuis 13 ans il y a
13 ans elle
baissait nous nous avons assumé de
porter des dispositifs pour soutenir les
collectivités les plus fragilisées par
l'inflation et notamment la hausse des
prix de
l'énergie cette hausse de la DGF n'est
pas une hausse en trompeleœuil qui n
concernerait que quelquesuns l'année
dernière pour la quasittalité des
communes la DGF est resté stable ou a
augmenté je le rappelle il n'y a pas si
longtemps que cela avec une autre
majorité elle avait baissé et beaucoup
baissé nous devons maintenant aller plus
loin c'est pourquoi je vous l'annonce je
souhaite que les préfets aient désormais
une vision pluriannuelle jusqu'en 2027
des dotations d'investissement pour
mieux accompagner les collectivités et
leur donner de la visibilité dans leurs
projets c'est pourquoi mon gouvernement
veillera toujours à ce que la lutte
nécessaire contre le dérèglement
climatique ne soit pas un frein au
développement des territoires je pense
notamment à la question duusan et je
salue tout le travail que vous avez mené
ici l'année dernière pour l'assouplir
permettre aux élus d'accomplir
pleinement leur mission c'est aussi les
protéger partout les élus sont
confrontés à des situations difficiles
tandu
et partout ils répondent présent tous me
parlent de leur passion pour leur mandat
mais beaucoup abordent aussi leur
découragement face à l'explosion des
incivilités des menaces et des attaques
nos élus sont en première ligne face à
une société qui se brutalise ils en sont
les premières victimes insulte menace de
mort frein d'une voiture coupée domicile
vandalisé menace homophobe et parfois
même famille attaqué je le dis
clairement qui attaque un élu attaque la
République attaque attaque notre modèle
démocratique attaque les fondements
mêmes de notre société toujours la
République devra la protection à ses
élus et avec le président de la
République et l'ensemble de mon
gouvernement nous serons toujours à leur
côté nous allons par exemple renforcer
notre droit et alourdir les peine prévu
contre ceux qui attaquent nos élus je
sais que des textes des lois avaient été
pris encore récemment sur ce sujet-là et
la réalité c'est que le sujet
fondamental c'est évidemment que la
réponse pénale soit au rendez-vous nous
avons d'ors et déjà pris des mesure pour
la renforcer mais c'est dans le cœur et
les racines de la société qu'il faut
agir évidemment qu'il faut punir et
sanctionner celui qui s'en prend à un
élu celui qui s'en prend un professeur
celui qui s'en prend un policier celui
qui s'en prend à celles et ceux qui
incarnent notre République mais en
cherchant à les à leur répondre et à les
sanctionner n'oublions jamais que la
priorité ça doit être de s'interroger
sur ce qui fait dans notre société qu'on
en arrive à avoir des personnes qui se
permettent de s'en prendre à ce point à
la République et là l'école je le dis
aussi elle a un rôle absolument
fondamental et tout ce que nous allons
faire sur le renforcement de
l'instruction civique sur la revue de
l'échelle des sanctions dans l'école sur
la capacité à prendre des sanctions
beaucoup plus jeunes sur des mineurs des
sanctions qui soient adaptées plutôt que
d'attendre qu'un jeune avant son âge
fasse commettre des infractions plus
graves pour le sanctionner lourdement
revenons-en au bon vieux principe de
sanction immédiate très tôt proportionné
mais qui permettent oui assume de le
dire même si ça n'est pas la mission
fondamentale de l'école d'éduquer des
jeunes et de leur faire comprendre ce
qu'est la
République quand ces violences
s'ajoutent aux lourdeur du mandat à
l'addition des normes qui contraignent
de plus en plus l'action des élus
parfois malheureusement certains
baissent les bras alors nous devons
faire plus et faire mieux pour les
soutenir dans leur
engagement je veux mettre en place un
véritable statut de l'élu local
permettant aux élus d'être mieux
protégés mieux emnis mieux valorisé je
m'appuierai pour cela là aussi sur des
travaux parlementaires je pense au
travaux de la sénatrice Françoise
[Applaudissements]
Gattel mais aussi à ce mais aussi à ceux
des députés violette spbout et Sébastien
Jumel qui ont également travaillé sur le
sujet vous pouvez aussi les applaudir il
s'engage pour les
élus
faciliter l'engagement faciliter les
conditions d'exercice des mandats
faciliter les reconversions après la vie
d'élu sur tous ces sujets nous pouvons
avancer ensemble unis et trouver des
accords au-delà des clivages partisans
protéger nos élus n'attend pas je
souhaite que nous avancions vite et que
des propositions puissent aboutir d'ici
la fin du premier trimestre enfin je
souhaite améliorer toujours notre vie et
notre démocratie locale aussi comme l'a
annoncé le président de la République
nous réformerons le mode de scrutin à
Paris Lyon et Marseille nous adopterons
un principe simple un habitant une voix
chaque électeur doit pouvoir élire son
maire beaucoup plus directement un texte
sera présenté d'ici la fin de
l'année nous continuerons le déploiement
du plan France ruralité qui va permettre
le retour de nos service publics dans
les territoires nous allons aider les
élus pour revitaliser les centr-villes
les centrebourgs comme nous avons
commencé à le faire avec les plans
action cœur de ville nous continuerons à
accompagner les territoires ruraux les
la dotation d'aménité rurale a été
doublé cette année et nous poursuivrons
cet engagement dans les années à venir
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs cette feuille de route a été
construite pour répondre aux
préoccupations de tous les élus à leur
contact et à leur écoute mais elle ne
marchera pas si on la met en œuvre
depuis Paris je continuerai à aller sur
le terrain sans relâche pour pour
échanger avec nos élus locaux car parler
aux élus locaux c'est toujours prendre
le pou du pays je continuerai à agir en
lien étroit avec les associations d'élus
dans le respect et l'écoute elles sont
déterminantes pour trouver des solutions
je continuerai bien sûr à agir avec le
Sénat car vous faites entendre la voix
des
territoires Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je viens de vous
faire part du Cap que suivra mon
gouvernement mon ambition autour du
projet du président de la République
vous la connaissez bâtir notre
souveraineté restaurer la fierté
française avoir pleinement le contrôle
de nos vies et notre destin en main
cette ambition je la porterai avec
toutes les femmes et les hommes de bonne
volonté prêt à agir pour notre pays avec
nous je la porterai avec nos élus locaux
engagés pour leur territoire et
déterminés à les défendre je la porterai
avec les Français en les écoutant
toujours en parlant toujours franchement
en agissant toujours résolument je
lappterai à l'Europe dans une Europe
résolue à construire une puissance
européenne capable de répondre aux
crises et d'agir au plus près de nos
concitoyens cet après-midi dans ce Sénat
Grand Conseil des communes de France de
gambeta dans ce Sénat profondément
républicain profondément attaché à nos
territoires et entièrement tourné vers
l'avenir j'ai confiance j'ai confiance
car je sais que nous avons l'amour de la
France en commun et l'envie d'agir en
partage j'ai confiance car on sait ici
dépasser les clivages pour agir ensemble
au service des Français et de l'intérêt
général de grands défis nous attendent
ensemble je vous propose de les relever
et de faire briller ensemble
fr je
vousci merci Monsieur le Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre merci dans la suite de notre
débat je vais maintenant donner la
parole aux orateurs de group le premier
orateur est le président Bruno rotill
pour le GR
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président chers collègues Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre euh votre nomination a
incontestablement une dimension
symbolique la jeunesse dont vous vous
réclamez et que vous revendiquez
l'audace aussi que euh vous portez comme
une bannière évoque dans l'esprit de
certains et peut-être d'abord dans
l'esprit du chef de l'État
les premiers matins ont sooleillés d'un
macronisme
triomphant lorsqu'il fallait penser
printemps mais ces jours-là sont loin
désormais nous sommes en hiver et face
aux chrises qui se multipli et parfois
s'emboî les unes dans les autres telle
la crise de l'agriculture les Français
seront àchacher non pas cette portée
symbolique d'une nomination mais à la
politique que vous allez conduire que
vous allez mener avec avec votre
gouvernement car l'engouement dont vous
bénéficiez
encore
encore est un atout mais ce n'est pas un
acquis vous savez plaire mais saurezvous
faire saurezv faire d'ailleurs ce que
vous nous promettez ce que le président
de la République nous a promis une
politique de réarmement et je voudrais
commencer mon intervention par cette
politique de réarmement parce qu'on peut
pas faire une bonne politique sans bon
constat
j'ai entendu le 31 décembre comme
beaucoup d'autres d'entre nous le
président de la République parler et se
satisfaire se vanter d'un réarement
économique
vraiment vraiment on est loin du plein
emploi le taux de chômage ne recule pas
il progresse il tengentera les 8 % de la
fin de l'année et nous sommes à la
traaine de l'Europe l'Allemagne est à un
peu plus de 3 % peut-on s'en contenter
peut-on s'en satisfait
on est loin aussi de la
réindustrialisation c'est vrai vous
l'avez souligné ici à ma place a
quelques instants la
désindustrialisation est sans doute
stoppée mais on est très loin de la
réindustrialisation la preuve le
commerce extérieur là encore quand on se
compare on se désole avantdernier des
pays
européens avec l'Espagne juste derrière
nous l'Espagne quant aux finances
publiqu vous avez perdu le contrôle là
aussi ce n'est pas avec l'Espagne c'est
avec la Belgique qu'on partage le
presque dernier an l'avantdernier an
beaucoup de pays 16 pays européens sont
désormais dans leur taux d'endettement
un taux d'endettement inférieur à 65% du
PIB vous avez indiqué que vous
maîtrisiez la dépense non avec le
rapporteur général nous l'avons encore
il y a quelques mois montré la dépense
n'est pas maîtrisée elle continue
d'augmenter et nous sommes à la traain
de l'Europe bien sûr et malheureusement
le problème français c'est que nous
cumulons des records de dépenses
publiques des records de prélèvement
obligatoire et des serv des services
publics qui s'effondre s'il y avait une
corrélation chers collègues entre le
niveau de la dépense publique et la
qualité des services publics mais alors
on serait à l'avant-garde du bonheur
universel et ça n'est pas le cas loin
sans
faux de fil en aiguille et de déficit en
déficit qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est la
dette qui ne cesse d'augmenter là encore
seulle la Grèce et l'Italie font moins
bien que la France sont font moins bien
que nous et ça place la France dans une
situation extrêmement périlleuse
pourquoi parce qu'avec une croissance
qui est molle une croissance potentielle
qui faiblit parce que la productivité
est en train de s'effondrer depuis 2019
les taux d'intérêt réel à long terme
remontent et vont nous placer dans cette
situation que je décris comme périlleuse
au moment où toute l'activité toute la
richesse produite de la France devra
servir uniquement justement au service
de la dette et quen sera-t-il des marges
de manœuvre dont nous avons besoin
cruellement besoin pour faire face aux
défi au choc le choc démographique vous
avez très peu parlé du vieillissement si
peu parleré de la datalité le choc
géopolitique le choc du réchauffement
climatique je vous ai entendu dire hier
que la planification écologique c'était
l'écologie populaire non l'écologie ne
doit pas être ne doit pas se faire en
tout cas sur le dos des plus modestes
d'entre nous je pense que c'est une
conviction que vous et moi on peut
partager qu'on doit partager mais très
franchement du point de vue du rarmement
économique en parler sans satisfaire
c'est comme une
hallucination je ne le vois pas nous ne
le voyons pas la France est des armé
voyons un moment puisque vous en avez
parlé il y a quelques instants
l'autorité le réarmement de l'État
l'autorité de l'État on a la
confirmation des chiffres qui ont été
publiés il y a quelques semaines par le
ministère de l'Intérieur catastrophique
par jour les coups et blessures ont
augmenté 1000 pratiquement 1000 actes de
coup des blessures quotidiennes les
violences sexuelles qui étaaiit une
priorité du quinquena annoncé comme tel
près de 240 par jour CER ce sont des
statistiques elles sont froides elles
sont désincarnées je vous assure que les
Français je vous assure que les Français
subissent ces statistiques dans leur
chair à travers eux-mêmes ou leurs amis
et leur famille et beaucoup de Français
trouvent que notre justice 70 % n'est
pas suffisamment ferme elle est trop
laxiste là encore ça n'est pas une
question de moyens c'est une question de
courage est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
renverser la table à renverser la table
par exemple en créant des courtes peines
des peines minimales enfin des places de
prison êtes-vous là encore prêt à
renverser la table pour que enfin on ait
un régime pénal despineurs
des mineurs adaptés à la
dangerosité des nouveaux ensuvagés qui
sont souvent délinquants ça c'est pas le
rôle de l'école ça c'est le rôle d'une
justice
pénale donc là encore pas de réarmement
un mot des souveraineté la souveraineté
budgétaire financière simplement pour
dire je parle sur le contrôle de notre
rapporur général que notre dette est
détenue à peu près à moitié par des
étrangers Napoléon avait une phrase qui
illustre bien la situation de la
souveraineté budgétaire de la France la
main qui donne la main qui prête est
toujours au-dessus de la main qui reçoit
il peut pas y avoir de souveraineté
financière lorsque on est si dépendant
de l'étranger et la voix de la France si
affaiblie en Europe ne n'allez pas
chercher plus loin un pays qui ne tient
pas sa dette qui ne tient pas ses GES
ses contte c'est une nation qui ne peut
pas tenir son rang et dont la voix
s'affaiblit dans le concert justement et
notamment européen on a parlé beaucoup
d'agriculture je vais en parler quelques
instants le malaise des agriculteurs
vient tout simplement qu'on les a
enfermé dans une tonaille impossible
intonal intonable et qui pousse au
suicide un trop grand grand nombre
d'entre eux toujours plus de liberté à
l'extérieur
d'ultralibéralisme et toujours plus de
dirigisme à l'intérieur ce sont les noes
Barbar du dirigisme à l'intérieur en
France et euh du libre échangisme à
l'extérieur c'est ce qui crée
aujourd'hui ce mal-être vous avez dit je
veux créer une sorte d'exception
agricole française la seule exception
agricole que connaissent aujourd'hui en
France nos agriculteurs c'est
l'exception normative c'est ce qui est
tu à petit fait parce que on importe une
agriculture en France qu'on interdit
justement sans doute pour préserver
l'environnement et notre santé
évidemment à nos agriculteurs de
produire vous avez les moyens vous avez
parlé de surtransposition prenez tout de
suite un décret interdisz tout de suite
ou plutôt accepter tout de suite les
mollécules qui sont elles interdites en
France mais autorisé en Espagne en
Allemagne en Europe rétablissez une
juste concurrence vous pouvez le faire
et il faut être conséquent votre groupe
au Parlement européen a voté toutes les
mesures de contrainte
environnementaliste de nos
agriculteurs il faut être conséquent
Emmanuel Macron veut le fédéralisme
leéral comment vouloir le fédéralisme le
fédéralisme chers collègues c'est que
toutes les décisions soient prises de
plus en plus à la majorité majorité
qualifiée et il voudrait pour le
Mercosur à lui seur empêcher l'Europe
d'avancer mais l'Europe avance sans lui
vous ne nous avez pas permis ici de dire
notre opposition au CA vous l'avez fait
à l'assemblée qui l'a ratifié grâce
notamment à votre majorité ici nous
voulons voter contre le CA nous sommes
cohérents nous sommes conséquents parce
que nous voulons préserver précisément
la souveraineté de la France
j'ajoute à ce panorama pour terminer le
bilan un bilan que vous trouviez solide
le bilan politique jamais le
rassemblement national n'a été aussi
élevé dans les sondages jamais il n'a
été aussi proche d'une prise de pouvoir
pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron avait indiqué qu'il
était le rempart il se posait comme le
rempart il ne n'aurait été que le
marche-pied parce qu'à force parce qu'à
force d'organiser méticuleusement un
face à faceace avantageux vous le faites
grimper bien sûr dans les sondages alors
voyez ce bilan il n'est pas solide il
est liquide vous voulez réarmer la
France soit soit nous le voulons nous
aussi mais n'attendez pas de nous que
nous devenions macronistes vous dites
j'ai confiance nous n'avons pas
confiance nous avons appris à nous
méfier aujourd'hui il faudra que cette
confiance vous puissiez la reconstruire
parce qu'aujourd'hui le sentiment qui
domine ici c'est précisément la défiance
mais nous ne serons jamais macroniste
parce que voyez nous sommes les
héritiers du général de Gaulle et nous
pensons que sur la pratique des
institutions comme de la vision de la
politique le macronisme est un
antigolisme sur d'abord les institutions
un gouvernement qui ne détermine plus
qui ne conduit plus la politique de la
nation un parlement totalement anémié on
a parlé vous avez parlé de la loi
immigration j'en reviens une loi
censurée qui n'aurait jamais été votter
ni dans l'une ni dans l'autre des
assemblées une loi promulguée une loi
censurée qui était voté très
majoritairement ici à l'Assemblée et une
loi au contraire censurée qui n'aurait
jamais été votée dans aucune de nos deux
assemblées et l'ame vous allez
contourner à nouveau le Parlement avec
la voie réglementaire c'est un parlement
qui n'a jamais été aussi diminué à coûp
d'ordonnan qui ne sont plus ratifié à
cou de règlement de lois qui ne sont
plus appliqué et de 493 mes chers
collègues le problème de cette pratique
institutionnelle c'est que bien sûr ces
instruments de coertion sont dans la
Constitution mais le général de Gaulle
comme Michel Debray croyait non pas à la
concentration des pouvoirs en un seul
mais au contraire pour reprendre la
formule de Debray à la collaboration des
pouvoirs aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron use
de ces pouvoirs coercitifs sans avoir la
contrepartie c'est-à-dire le recours au
référendum ou même au peuple voilà
pourquoi il y a un point qui est
déséquilibre notre vie politique et
notre démocratie et puis la vision de la
politique de GA avait cette phrase la
politique c'est l'action pour un idéal à
travers des réalités l'action désormais
a été supplantée par la communication
c'est terrible plus la politique est
impuissante pu elle se perd dans la
surcommunication à force de vouloir
crever l'écran la politique en crève
l'idéal l'idéal battu en brèche par
l'opportunisme mes chers collègues le
débauchage le débauchage ne fait ni de
bien à la démocratie ni de bien ni de
bien à la politique parce que signifiait
que tout se vaut la droite comme la
gauche la fidélité comme les revirements
ça veut dire que rien ne vaut et que
tout est faux et je m'honore qu'ici au
Sénat il y ait des femmes des hommes de
loyauté à gauche comme à droite qui
considéront toujours que l'ambition est
en dessous de la conviction la
conviction au-dessus de
quant à la réalité quant à la réalité
enentend le président de la République
dire que les émeutes c'est parce que les
jeunes étaient oisifs franchement les
Français n'ont pas compris alors
Monsieur le Premier Ministre la tâche
est herculienne la fonction est
difficile quand un premier ministre
existe il inquiète quand il n'existe pas
il manque mais justement nous traversons
sont un moment telllurique et dans un
moment telllurique on peut pas
simplement continuer les bilans on peut
pas simplement faire des ajustements
ajuster faire quelques petites mesures
il faut revoir les principes des
principes nouveaux ce que vous n'avez
pas dit ici à cette tribune et c'est ce
que nous attendons en revanche vous ai
entendu vous voulez vous adresser aux
Français ordinaire pourquoi pas mais
alors adressez-vous à nos
compatriotes non pas dans la langue du
marketing de la segmentation
catégorielle mais parlez-leur comme un
seul peuple parlez-leur la langue de
l'unité abandonnez-le en même temps
rompez avec le macronisme vous voulez
parler à tous ces Français ordinaires
mais alors faites comme le général de
Gaulle pratiquez la politique de la
majorité nationale rendez aux Français
ordinaires rendez à cette France-là bien
sûr cette capacité cette liberté cette
liberté cette école cette école qui
instruisent et qui ne déconstruisent pas
rendez-lui ce travail bien sûr au-delà
de la spicardisation rendez-lui sa
souveraineté rendez aux maires
évidemment cette liberté les maires ne
demandent pas l'Ô les maires souffr du
même mal que les agriculteurs ce mal
c'est l'overdose de norm les maires
veulent un réarmement civique parce que
eux sont au service de la cité la cité
le civisme et puis les mirres rendez à
cette France là ses frontières pour que
elle puisse se protéger rendez-lui sa
souveraineté c'est-à-dire sa liberté en
résumé rendez au français ordinaire des
raisons d'espérer dans la France cette
France que nous aimons et cette France
que nous voulons servir de tout notre
cœur merci de votre
attention la
parole la parole est au président
Patrick
canner pour le groupe social
écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier ministre mes chers
collègues le 9 janvier dernier vous avez
accepté la mission que vous a confié
Emmanuel Macron à la tête du
gouvernement ce jour-là vous avez
accepté d'endosser un lourd passif celui
d'une politique libérale et
réactionnaire mené depuis bientôt 7 ans
vous avez aussi acceptter d'End doser
une lourde responsabilité celle de
conduire ce rouleau compresseur
d'injustice et de casasse sociale vos
premières semaines à matigon en sont
l'édifiant témoignage des blindés sur
les autoroutes une école publique
insultée une facture d'électricité qui
explose la franchise médicale doublée
rien ne semble vous arrêter pourtant je
vous le dis les Français sont à bout je
ne parle pas des plus riches d'entre eux
qui peuvent continuer à s'enrichir sans
limite sans scrupule je parle de celles
et ceux qui ne peuvent compter que sur
leur travail pour vivre et qui galèent
vous ne le voyez pas ou vous ne voulez
pas le voir ces Français sont épuisés
par la politique que vous menez depuis
2017 vous ne voulez pas voir qu'ils ont
élu Emmanuel Macron par deux fois pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite ils ne
lui ont pas donné le mandat pour
dérouler cette politique de régression
les élections législative et sénatorial
ont déjà sanctionné votre politique la
prochaine étape ce sera le 9 juin lors
des élections européennes ce contexte
aurait dû vous conduire à un réflexe
d'écoute voire d'humilité dans votre
exercice du pouvoir à privilégier la
concertation le dialogue social la
réalité est tout autre ne parvenant pas
à emporter l'adhésion des Français vous
avez fait le choix du passage en force
permanent et de l'utilisation draisonné
du 49 alinéa 3 pire vous avez démontré
que vous étiez prêt à fragiliser notre
État de droit pour parvenir à vos fins
en feignant de satisfaire les appétits
pour ne pas dire les fantasmes de la
droite sur la loi immigration vous êtes
cyniquement défaussé sur le Conseil
constitutionnel vous avez ouvert la voix
à la remise en cause de nos institution
et de notre Constitution et je le dis
ici jamais je n'oublierai les propos
irresponsables tenus par la droite dite
républicaine à leur encontre ces propos
m'ont indigné je les condamne avec force
comme je condamne la responsabilité du
président de la République dans cette
grave dérive ce jeullà est dangereux et
nous en sortons tous perdants tous sauf
celle qui s'en frotte avidement les
mains l'extrême droite la même extrême
droite qui se réjouit de votre bilan
depuis 7 ans qui se délecte de voir nos
services publics mis à mal nos CPS
intermédiaires ignorer la fracturation
sociale assumer l'extrême droite qui n'a
plus qu'à déambuler sereinement sur le
tapis rouge que vous lui déroulez
monsieur le Premier ministre je fais
partie de ceux qui croient que notre
pays peut résister à la tentation brune
et nausée à bonde de l'extrême droite
pas par principe pas simplement par
l'attachement des Français à nos valeurs
républicaines car les valeurs
républicaines on n a rien à faire qu'on
n pas quand on n' pas les moyens de
nourrir correctement ses enfants quand
on voit que les efforts reposent
toujours sur les mêmes je vous en prie
retirez vos illères et cessz d'alimenter
le Terrot des populistes monsieur le
Premier ministre nous sommes ici dans la
chambre des territoire vous avez en face
de vous des parlementaires en contact
permanent avec nos élus locaux des élus
locaux qui mieux que quiconque entendent
l'amertume des Français qui d'élection
en élection voit de plus en plus de
leurs habitants qui part dépit se laisse
tenter par le RN ces élus sont
aujourd'hui en colère ils sont en colère
parce qu'ils sont en première ligne
auprès de nos concitoyens qu'ils n'ont
pas les moyens de répondre à leurs
besoins ils sont en colère parce que
l'attente était forte parce que le
Président de la République s'était
engagé à ouvrir une nouvelle donne
territoriale quen reste-t-il aujourd'hui
depuis votre arrivée au pouvoir les
collectivités territoriales ont été
considérées par le gouvernement comme
une variable d'ajustement des comptes
publics chaque jour les élus que je
rencontre m'alertent sur les
conséquences de votre politique fiscale
avec pour seulomme la diminution des
impôts la suppression de la CVAE en est
le dernier exemple plus de transfert de
compétences mais moins de moyens les
élus locaux sont aussi en colère face à
votre immobilisme en matière de
décentralisation la loi 3DS censé
représenter un nouvel acte en la matière
ne fut qu'un rendez-vous manqué comme si
l'excès de centralisation n'avait pas
montré ses limites de la crise des
gilets jaunes à la crise sanitaire notre
groupe croit en la force de l'État et
des collectivités qui assure l'unité
nationale et l'égalité entre les
citoyens qu'il se trouent sur l'hexagone
ou sur les outrmerses si l'État est
garant de ces principes l'état
centralisateur ne peut en garantir seul
l'efficacité et nous avons des idées
d'abord donner une bouffée d'oxygène aux
élus indexer la dotation globale de
fonctionnement sur l'inflation renforcer
la dotation pour l'exercice des mandats
locaux et parce que les finances locales
doivent être sécurisés nous voulons
aller plus loin nous vous demandons une
loi de financement des collectivités
territoriales elle permettrait de
définir de manière plus annuel les
grands enjeux de l'investissement local
et d'assurer l'autonomie financière des
collectivités territoriales enfin nous
voulons un statut pour l'élu cela a été
évoqué intimidation violence agression
et ce paroxisme extraordinaire du mois
de juin dernier avec les révoltes
urbaines incandescence qui nous alerte
et qui exige des réponses fortes et j'y
viens d'abord d'abord remettre la
justice au cœur de nos politiques
publiques depuis 2017 les droits c'est
pour les nantis les devoirs c'est pour
les petits je crois monsieur le Premier
ministre que vous ne musurez pas les
conséquences de ce sentiment d'injustice
chez nos concitoyens vous ne mesurez pas
le malaise et le ressentiment que cela
peut provoquer c'est un élu du Nord qui
vous le dit d'un territoire que le
déclassement conduit au désespoir un
désespoir que vos politiques continuent
d'amplifier comment comprendre quand on
a peine à boucl ces fins de mois que des
multinationales enregistrent des
bénéfices records dans les secteurs du
pétrole du gaz des transports sans que
ces Bénéfic ne viennent contribuer à la
solidarité nationale comment comprendre
que pendant ce temps-là vous augmentez
de 10 % la facture d'électricité les
Français comment comprendre l'explosion
des hauts revenus exonéré d'impôt sur la
fortune les réponse que vous apportez ce
sont des primes pardonnez-moi monsieur
le Premier ministre mais si elles
apportent une réponse d'urgence
bienvenue pour les Français les plus
modestes ces primes sont avant tout du
bricolage on ne gouverne pas un pays à
coup de rustine qui n'apporte aucune
réponse de long terme là encore puisque
vous semblez à cour d'idée en voici
quelquesunes mettez en place une taxe
sur les super profits dans les secteurs
de l'énergie des transport instaurer un
ISF climatique ou encore établisser les
impôts de production il s'agit là de
répondre à un besoin réel renflouer les
caisses de l'État pour financer des
politiques publiques pour tous il s'agit
aussi d'un signal qui n'est pas que
symbolique non les classes moyennes
n'ont pas à supporter tous les efforts
ces efforts doivent être répartis
suivant les moyens de chacun voilà une
ambition politique nouvelle car les
Français ne demandent pas l'omô ils
demandent de vivre dignement de leur
travail Vous vous targuez d'avoir
d'avoir diminué le taux de chômage mais
vous avez augmenté le nombre de
travailleurs pauvres vous avez favorisé
un marché du travail au service des
entreprises sans contrepartie pour les
salariés la baisse du chômage ne dit
rien des difficultés croissant de nos
concitoyens à se nourrir se loger se
chauffer se soigner vous dites
vouloir difficile
désmicardiser la France mais quel aveu
qui est responsable de ce smicardisation
quand elle concerne 17% des salariés
français nul ne peut se prévaloir de sa
propre turpitude contrairement à vous
nous nous ne proposons pas une nouvelle
baisse des charges mais une véritable
politique de revalorisation salariale
pour chaque citoyen et qu'il soit
justement rémunéré une juste
rémunération pour mieux vivre et en
premier lieu se loger vous n'avez aucune
vision pour la politique du logement la
dérégulation ne constitue pas une
politique Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tout le secteur économique de la
construction subit une crise sans
précédent avec des entreprises et des
emplois menacés des élus locaux désarmés
en réponse Vous avez sapé le modèle
économique du logement soci et
maintenant vous vous attaquez désormais
au fondement de la loi SRU c'est
irresponsable ce que nous proposons
d'abord réhabiliter la construction en
ville comme en milieu rural et si
l'objectif du zan est essentiel il doit
être équilibré avec les aspirations des
Français et coconstruit avec les élus
locaux ensuite repenser la place des
collectivités dans les politiques de
logement pour permettre l'adaptation
local nécessaire renforcer leurs moyens
leur donner des outils propres de
régulation favoriser une reprise de la
construction logement avec une maîtrise
de l' volée des prix du foncier et la
généralisation de l'encadrement des
loyers ne serait-ce que dans les zones
tendues et enfin réévaluer les APL
oui notre pays s'enfonce vers une
fracturation de la société qui atteindra
bientôt un point de non retour et le
monde agricole nous en donne une
nouvelle illustration la mobilisation
des agriculteurs est aujourd'hui une
expression flagrante de cette colère qui
gronde une colère qui trouve ses
origines dans une crise structurelle à
appelant à des réformes d'ampleur votre
gouvernement manque une nouvelle fois
d'une vision d'ensemble et d'un projet
mobilisateur ce que nous proposons une
véritable transition de notre modèle
agricole vers davantage de durabilité et
de reconnaissance du travail rendu
condition indispensabl pour pour offrir
des perspective juste à nos agriculteurs
c'est
l'objectif monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le Président de la commission
d'enquête que nous réclamons sur la
question des revenus agricoles et des
relations commerciales agro-alimentaires
il est temps qu'un diagnostic clair
précis transparent soit posé sur des
pratiques de certains opérateurs
économiques afin de mettre fin à un
système qui tue à petit feu notre
agriculture les annonces que vous avez
fait hier et encore aujourd'hui ne sont
pas du niveau pour conclure je souhaite
évoquer les dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui seront demain avec nous à
gauche dans la rue pour défendre notre
école publique laïque et gratuite car
aujourd'hui vous la mettez en danger
vous continuez de la fragiliser en
supprimant des poste d'enseignant encore
650 cette année comble du cynisme votre
Ministre accuse ensuite l'école publique
d'être responsable d'une fragilité que
vous avez provoqué en fin de compte
quelle est votre vision pour l'école
brandir les tendards du choc des savoirs
ne fait pas une politique publique ce
qui ronge aujourd'hui l'école c'est
l'absence de mixité sociale ce qui ronge
notre société c'est le séparatisme dès
le plus jeune âge face à cela que
proposez-vous vous prenez le retour de
l'uniforme à l'école la labellisation
des manuels scolaires et le placement en
internat une vision étriquée vieillote
qui ne répond qu'à une seule logique
l'autoritarisme plutôt que la pédagogie
Monsieur le Premier Ministre hier vous
avez affirmé je vous
cite que vous voyez davantage de raison
d'espérer que de
douter permettez-moi de vous dire
Monsieur le Premier Ministre que l'on
doute de la place de la France sur le
plan international que l'on doute de
votre attachement à la démocratie et à
nos institutions que l'on doute de votre
capacité à assurer notre souveraineté
oui que l'on doute de votre gouvernement
macrosiste l'illusion
macroniste du social libéralisme de 2017
aura duré un
printemps aucun enseignement n'a été
tiré des multiples crise sociale dans
ces deux quinquen le libéralisme
antisocial du président de la République
ne trompe plus personne vous n'avez fait
que semer les graines de la colère qui
sont en train de germer sur le terreau
de vos choix de société et votre
vocabulaire guerrier n'est que le signe
avant tout d'une grande faiblesse les
relan réactionnaires et la course folle
aux alliances opportuniste ont le don
non seulement de nous faire douter mais
nous oblige surtout à agir pour les
Françaises pour les Français notre
groupe portera et portera des solutions
celle d'un avenir solidaire et durable
je vous
remercie
merci la parole est maintenant au
président Hervé
[Applaudissements]
Marseille pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste monsieur le président
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames les ministres
mes chers collègues effectivement hier
nous avons écouté ici en stéréo votre
discours lu avec beaucoup de conviction
et de tonicité par Monsieur le Ministre
de l'économie
c'est un exercice sacrificiel auquel
nous
compatissons monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez bien fait deevenenir
aujourd'hui pour préciser les choses
nous avons retenu quand même des phrases
en France tout est possible en le disant
vous pensez à ce qui peut être positif
bien sûr mais malheureusement ça marche
dans les deux sens et la France est
effectivement capable du meilleur mais
aussi de performance moins enviable pour
faire du tout est possible une formule
de confiance et d'espoir nous avons
apprécié votre capacité à aborder tous
les sujets y compris ceux qui fâchent
qui irritent au quotidien ou plus
largement le sentiment d'impuissance de
l'action publique poison de notre
démocratie quant à vos orientations
cardinales désmicardisé déverrouillés
débureaucratisé comment ne pas y
souscrire ces grands axes vous les
mettez au service du réarmement de notre
pays permettez un vieux matou né en
de vous proposer un autre terme bien
plus classique mais plus important à mes
yeux celui de justice réarmé est sans
doute nécessaire mais pour uneé servir
la justice car c'est le sentiment
d'injustice et d'iniéquité qui fragilise
aujourd'hui notre société la colère
agricole on vient d'en parler en est la
caricature les agriculteurs sont au
carrefour d'une quadruple injustice
territoriale d'abord opposition accrue
d'un monde qui se sent donné des classés
économique les agriculteurs sont les
parents pauvres du partage de la de la
valeur sociale et culturel celle des
travailleurs de ceux qui se lèvent tôt
face aux injonctions des coles blancs
hors sol l'injustice de vivre avec le
sentiment de devoir abandonner ses
valeurs enfin justice injustice face à
des normes et des contraintes françaises
ou européennes qui ne pèsent pas sur
leurs concurrents d'autres pays chez
nous l'injustice commence dès la
naissance elle dépend du milieu mais
aussi du lieu où l'on vient au monde le
président de la République l'a reconnu
nous ne garantissons pas l'égalité de
tous les enfants de la République et
pour cause aujourd'hui naître à la
campagne c'est souvent naître dans un
désert médical là réside sans doute
actuellement l'injustice territoriale la
plus insupportable or vous l'avez
justement souligné nous ne pouvons pas
attendre gentiment que la fin du numérus
closis produit ses effets régulariser
les médecins étrangers n'y suffira même
pas il faudra avoir le courage et vous
venez de le dire à l'instant d'élargir
les délégations d'actes par
expérimentation plus globalement pour
tâcher de remédier à l'injustice
territoriale le Sénat plaide pour une
décentralisation régénérée qui restitue
des marges aux collectivités qui
insuffle plus d'équité que d'égalité
formelle tel est l'esprit de la
différenciation que nous appelons de nos
vœux vos mots sont encourageant la
décentralisation n'a pas la place qui
doit lui revenir gageons que vos
propositions permett d'avancer nous
espérons que votre arrivée signe la fin
de ce rendez-vous manqué avec les
collectivités depuis tant d'années
l'école est aussi un lieu d'injustice
persistante certes on a restreint le
nombre d'élèves par classe dans les
zones prioritaires mais tant reste à
faire bien sûr l'instruction civique
c'est important nous aussi nous sommes
favorables au retour de l'uniforme mais
le véritable enjeu c'est le retour du
mérite de l'excellence du respect des
enseignants pour y parvenir l'école a
besoin d'un CAP clair comme vous l'avez
fortement comme vous l'avez justement
déclaré tout n'est pas question de
moyens il n'y avait pas besoin d'argent
pour abandonner la méthode globale prené
pendant des décennies par des idéologues
dans cette France où tout est possible
le sentiment d'injustice habite aussi
les classes moyennes celle qui contribu
sans recevoir comme vous l'avez dit cela
ne peut plus durer ceci appelle de ma
part deux remarques d'abord les
fiscalités de l'immobilier et des
successions sont les plus mal vécus par
les classes moy
votre ouverture dans leur direction doit
être l'occasion d'évoluer dans cette
matière ensuite la fraudte sociale et
fiscale est au cœur de leur malaise nos
concitoyens méritant ne peuvent plus
supporter de voir d'un côté les
prestations sociales méticuleusement
détournées et de l'autre une poignée
d'entreprise voyou s'exiler pour
échapper à toute contribution aux
charges publiques il faut mener une
guerre sans merci à la fraude et à
l'évasion sous toutes ses formes
l'injustice se vit aussi de plus en plus
dans la question du loge
nous alertons depuis des mois sur la
crise qui vient elle est désormais
présente vous avez déclaré vouloir la
prendre à bras le cor cependant il n'est
pas certain que la simplification des
normes la réquisition des bâtiments vide
ou l'intégration du logement
intermédiaire dans les critères de la
loi et ces rues suffiront ce sont des
mesures pertinentes qui étaient attendu
mais plusieurs de centaines de milliers
de logements manquent aujourd'hui
comment se dégager du foncier avec les
problèmes du zan en particulier vous
l'avez souligné il il faudra adapter le
zan dans son application tout ne pourra
pas reposer sur la seule densification
la transition écologique soulève
également un enjeu majeur de justice et
d'équité car cette transition aussi
vitale et nécessaire soit-elle va faire
des perdants je pense en particulier aux
petits propriétaires qui vont être
plombés par le DPE ou aux artisans que
les afeu vont empêcher de travailler
Monsieur le Premier Ministre l'injustice
se niche jusque dans les derniers jours
de la vie la dépendance est l'un des
défis majeur qu'il nous faut relever
aujourd'hui avec le vieillissement de la
population c'est toute la société qui
doit se
réinventer nous ne pouvons pourtant plus
procrastiner le modèle social et
financier est au bord de l'implosion
c'est maintenant qu'il faut agir enfin
les inégalités et les injustices sont
intergénérationnelles ce qui pose
aujourd'hui la question de la dette et
des déficits s'il nous faut maîtriser la
trajectoire de nos finances publiques
c'est bien sûr pour recouvrir des marges
de manœuvre mais c'est aussi pour
rétablir une équité intergénérationnelle
or nous n'en prenons pas le chemin cette
année notre pays devra emprunter 285
milliards d'euros c'est plus que le PIB
du Portugal et la charge de la dette
devra bondir de 50 % d'ici à
2027 maîtriser les dépenses c'est bien
sûr faire des économies mais c'est
surtout faire des réformes de structure
sans attendre le retour des vaches
grasses pour terminer revenons à votre
état civil si vous le permettez monsieur
le Premier ministre
car nous pouvions attendre d'un jeune
chef du gouvernement qu'il nous ouvre
sur le futur qu'il nous parle
d'intelligence artificielle d'hydrogène
vert d'espace de génétique de ce monde
en transformation pour ne pas dire en
ébullition sur lequel nous devons nous
repositionner on n a pas parlé parce que
vous êtes nous sommes rattrapés par les
problèmes du passé que nous n'avons pas
pu résoudre pourtant vous avez cherché à
nous transmettre l'essentiel l'optimisme
et la
détermination comme vous nous savons que
notre avenir sera européen ou ne sera
pas ce qui n'interdit pas d'être
critique vis-à-vis de l'Europe que l'on
a construite trop technocratique et qui
n'est pas celle dont nous rêvions
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous êtes
ici au Sénat et depuis les législatives
de 2022 c'est ici pour l'essentiel qu'on
fabrique les principales lois sans le
Sénat pas de réforme des retraites sans
le Sénat pas de loi d'immigration dè
votre nomination vous êtes venu à la
rencontre du Sénat en participant à la
conférence des présidents nous avons été
sensibles à ce geste qui constitue un
encouragement mes collègues Bruno rillot
et Patrick caner ont eu l'occasion de
vous dire à ce moment précis que comme
nous ils étaient ouverts au dialogue
mais hosti à la coconstruction
c'est-à-dire à l'association des
parlementaires à l'élaboration du projet
de loi avant son dépôt au Parlement car
cette méthode lit les parlementaires
sans leur permettre de véritablement
enrichir ou modifier les textes en
revanche nous sommes favorables à la
construction parlementaire lors de
l'examen des textes c'est la différence
entre coconstruction et construction
d'ailleurs si les textes ont été votés
depuis 2 ans c'est bien parce qu'il y a
eu des compromis des accords des
constructions qui ont permis d'aboutir
face à notre impuissance nous n'avons
plus les moyens de chercher des
responsables que ce soit le Conseil
constitutionnel Bruxelles les
institutions judiciaires nous devons
supporter 3000 milliards de dettes les
agriculteurs bloquent les routes
l'inflation ronge le pouvoir d'achat la
guerre frappe aux porte de l'Europe
efface peu à peu l'Arménie de la carte
et embrase le proche- Orient avec
l'ombre inquiétante de l'Iran et le
possible retour de Donald Trump nous
pensons que le dialogue avec le
Parlement et singulièrement avec le
Sénat doit être fertile nous devons nous
écouter et nous devons rechercher les
solutions les plus collectifes possibles
alors Monsieur le Premier Ministre cette
responsabilité elle pèse sur vos épaules
elle pèse aussi sur nos épaules si vous
échouez si nous échouons vous et nous
savons qui arbitrera nos différents en
2027 et alors il sera trop tard pour
pleurer sur le lait renversé je vous
remercie monsieur le
président la parole est au président
François patria pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendant monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues chers collègues nous avons
écouté dans le calme vos contestations
sans appel permettez à ceux qui ontussi
des convictions et qui les place bien
au-dessus de leur ambition de pouvoir
s'exprimer aussi pour dire que nous
n'avons pas même vision bien évidemment
la politique la politique est l'art
d'imaginer et de construire un projet
collectif ce projet le président de la
République en a posé les jalons depuis
2017 et les Français lui ont renouvelé
leur conscience leur confiance en 2022
afin de le poursuivre lors des
législatives de 2022 les Français ont
adressé un message aux élus de la nation
ils appelaient à un dialogue et un
travail concerté avec la majorité
présidentielle malheureusement nous nous
sommes trop souvent heurtés au refus du
compromis politique à la différence du
Sénat attaché à la culture du dialogue
républicain l'Assemblée nationale n'a
pas su cultiver cet état d'esprit la
majorité plurielle s'est affirmé avant
tout comme une majorité
d'empêchement la minorité plurielle
comme une majorité d'empêchement et
c'est en refusant toute maattendue
marquant ainsi son devoir vis-à-vis des
Français notre devoir monsieur le
Premier ministre c'est de poursuivre le
projet de réform au profondeurs de notre
pays qui peut rester qui ne peut rester
statique alors que les cris se multiplie
sur l'ensemble de la planète face à ces
crise vous nous avez appelé monsieur le
Premier ministre à construire ensemble
et abandonner des postures politiciennes
vous nous avez appelé à agir plutôt qu'à
réagir dans l'intérêt des Français je
partage de votre analyse je partage
aussi la fierté du chemin parcouru
depuis 7 ans votre nomination est une
nouvelle étape nous en conservons le
même cap libéré protégé transformé uni
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
la lourde tâche de veiller à la
traduction en acte concret la volonté
réformatrice formulée par le Président
vous nous avez rappelé que la France
n'est pas une nation qui subit elle ne
l'a pas été elle ne l'est pas
aujourd'hui elle ne lera pas demain
grâce à notre travail vous souhaitez
agir vite en faisant preuve de lucidité
de pragmatisme d'efficacité et d'audace
votre méthode est simple et efficace
prendre rapidement des décisions
compréhensibles pour les Français et
vous l'avez dém vendredi lors de votre
visite dans le Sud-Ouest en effet cette
méthode est déjà à l'épreuve la crise
que traverse le monde agricole est
symptomatique des mots français des mots
français parce que la bureaucratisation
et l'empilement des normes
particulièrement denses ont entretenu le
mal-être d'une profession qui a souvent
été mal présenté mal comprise mal et qui
et qui en souffre des mots qui dépassent
nos frontières aussi parce que les mêmes
causes ont les mêmes les mêmes effets
chez nos voisins européens cette crise
agricole à d'autres racines je pense aux
concurrence déloyal vous l'avez évoqué à
à la nécessité d'instaurer des clauses
miroires dans les traités internationaux
je pense aussi à la complexification
notre objectif est de garder notre notre
souveraineté alimentaire et vos annonces
depuis vendredi vont dans ce sens àer
aller à la transition écologique à la
souveraineté alimentaire et agricole
allier la transition écologique pardon
et la souveraineté alimentaire agricole
c'est ça l'exception agricole française
que nous devons défendre mais cette
trans transition doit être supportable
tant par les producteurs que par les
consommateurs reconquérir une
souveraineté perdue est notre devoir
assumer depuis 2017 il faut poursuivre
dans la souveraineté industrielle car
vous l'avez rappelé nous créons
aujourd'hui plus d'emplois que nous en
détruisons dans le secteur industriel et
nous réouvrons des usines de la
souveraineté énergétique car nous avons
entrepris de relancer la filière
nucléaire alors que nous avions perdu
l'habitude de mettre en service des
centrales dans la souveraineté militaire
puisque nous avons voté la dernière LPM
ici une des plus importantes Hauses du
budget des armées que notre pays est
connu afin de faire face aux multiples
fronts et de formes de confrontation
aujourd'hui dans la souveraineté à nos
frontières avec le renforcement de notre
arsenal législatif mais aussi la notre
capacité d'intégration j'ai II une
pensée pour le territoire de Mayotte qui
fait face à une crise migratoire sans
précédent à laquelle la fermeté doit
répondre en effet mes chers collègues
nos outres mères font le rayonnement de
la France à travers le monde mais sont
trop souvent les parents pauvres de nos
politiques publiques leurs difficultés
sont décuplées par leur situation
géographique leurs problématiques sont à
la fois les mêmes que dans l'exagon mais
leur intensité est parfois plus aigu en
Guyane où la protection du territoire de
sa biodiversité de nos frontières coûte
encore la vie à nos militaires à qui
nous pensons aujourd'hui aux Antilles où
la crise des Sargasses et de la clord
desconne handicape les territoires qui
doivent faire face à la vie chè à Wall
Futuna territoire silintoin où l'État
doit faire pour préserver le contrat
social en Polynésie qui do devra dans
les années à venir faire face à la
montée des océans à l'extension de
l'influence chinoise dans le Pacifique à
la réunion qui a subi récemment le
cyclone Béal un des plus puissants
queoire que ce territoire a été affronté
et qui malheureusement pourrait se
répéter à l'avenir avec le dérèglement
climatique face à l'urgence climatique
on ne fera pas d'écologie contre le
peuple c'est au contraire une écologie
populaire avec les Français qui
réconcilier le climat et la croissance
qui permettra de construire la France du
21e siècle l'écologie punitive de fait
qu'entretenir la division là où nous
avons besoin d'union monsieur le Premier
ministre vous avez porté un message
force pour le mérite notre majorité a
toujours œuvré pour que le travail pai
en 2017 déjà nous avons baissé les
cotisations salariales pour que les
actifs gagnent rapidement pouvoir
d'achat c'était une mesure de bon sens
sans tracat pour les Français il nous
faut prolonger une politique qui mette
en valeur le travail les annonces que
vous avez formulé hier vont dans ce sens
et nous les saluons travail souveraineté
autorité voilà la LI la laine tracée
dans vos propos devant nous cet
après-midi rappelez celle d'hier voilà
ce qu'il nous faut collectivement
construire avec des élus locaux pour que
tous nos concitoyens gardent la
confiance et l'espoir monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez voulu tracer
une feuille de route qui vous ressemble
pragmatique concise et structurée mais
vous n'avez pas oublié de faire prendre
racine dans le travail mené par vos
prédcessesseurs ceux qui nous ont
accompagné avant je pense à Édouard
Philippe à Jean Castex vous les avez
cité hier à Élizabeth borne dont je veux
souligner ici l'action déterminée au
service de notre pays nous avons porté
ensemble des textes majeurs ces derniers
mois prendre racine dans le travail mené
par vos prédécesseurs c'est aussi
rappeler que tous les territoires ont
été concernés par nos réformes qu'il
soit métropolitains urbains ou ruraux
contrairement à ce que j'entends la
ruralité n'a pas été oubliée et j'y vis
chaque chaque jour notamment ce qui
concerne le renforcement des services
publics de proximité nous avons
également investi fortement dans l'école
dans la santé dans la sécurité et dans
la justice aujourd'hui nous le savons il
faut accélérer je sais bien que le mot
réarmé vous fait sourire mais il
soulligne notre détermination à
renforcer notre pays en matière
académique sociale économique
technologique et innovante agir dans
cette direction c'est le choix de notre
indépendance et de notre souveraineté
mais c'est aussi faire le choix de la
solidarité et de l'attention aux autres
car une France plus forte c'est une
France plus juste notamment auprès des
classes moyennes dans vous avez fait
votre priorité cet objectif d'une France
plus forte et plus juste je sais qu'il
est largement partagé par les élus de
tout bord nous avons en partage chers
collègues l'amour de ce pays et nous
savons que l'une des clés du succès pour
notre nation c'est de travailler avec le
gouvernement avec les élus les
partenaires sociaux les forces vives
pour assumer ensemble les grandes
ambitions nationales c'est ça aussi le
dépassement la crise suppose audace
action efficacité ces qualités mes chers
collègues aucune une formation politique
non a le monopole c'est pourquoi j'en
appelle avec les sénateurs RDPI de la
métropole et d'outres mè à l'esprit de
responsabilité qui nous anime dans cet
hémicycle et grâce auquel nous savons
conduire des débats nourris mais
constructifs et trouver ensemble des
voies d'accord alors Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous nous avez appelé vous nous
avez rappelé le cap vous nous avez dit
la méthode nous savons votre
détermination vous connaissez notre
fidélité notre loyauté au prjet
présidentiel vous souhaitez être un
premier ministre de terrain nous serons
à vos côté je vous remerci
merci monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président la parole est à madame la
Présidente Cécile cuerman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
kanaki vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers
collègues monsieur le Premier ministre
et malgré votre jeunesse vous nêtes pas
un nouveau né dans l'entourage du
président Emmanuel Macron les crises
sont là Monsieur le Premier Ministre et
elle génèent chez nos compatriotes une
angoisse renforcée de moins en moins
aggravée par la multiplication des
conflits sur la planète de tout temps la
peur qui marque les peuples c'est la
guerre nous qui portons ce combat au
cœur de notre action savons qu'il ne
peut y avoir de progrès social de
justice en temps de guerre ce grand des
ordres du monde s'exprime en Ukraine en
Israël en Palestine et plus
particulièrement à Gaza mais aussi en
Arménie au Yémen au Kurdistan cette
situation exige que les nations les plus
influentes comme la nôtre déploient des
efforts considérable pour que la
diplomatie prévale à ce monde en crise
répondent des crises intérieures
profondes notre peuple souffre sur fond
d'inégalité financière et sociale
croissante la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
la crise de notre système de santé les
défaillances accélérées du service
public nuisent la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans l'avenir pour eux et
pour leurs enfants alors que 46
milliards d'euros ont été remis aux
actionnaires du CAC 40 en 2023 un record
11 millions de personnes ne mangent pas
à leur fin en France l'inflation
dévastatrice 10 % en 2 ans accélère cet
appauvrissement les chiffres de
l'alimentaire vous les connaissez mais
il faut les répéter plus 12 % en moyenne
plus 20 % pour nombre de produits
alimentaires de base et pourtant les
salaires ne suivent pas vous voulez
Monsieur le Premier
Ministre désmicardiser pardon on y
arrive vous voulez désmicardiser la
France mais vous ne proposez rien pour
augmenter les salaires vous culpabilisez
les salariés les les chômeurs mais
jamais vous ne pointez la responsabilité
fondamentale des plus riches et
actionnaires de tout poil j'ai comme
nombre d'entre vous assisté à de
nombreuses cérémonies de vœux ces
dernières
semaines quelle inquiétude quand
j'entends que plus de la moitié des
enfants bénéficient dans des communes de
la cantine à 1 € là où le dispositif est
déployé c'est dire si la pauvreté touche
l'ensemble de notre pays cette France
appauvr elle ne peut plus se chauffer
correctement et Monsieur le Maire votre
Ministre assine qu'au nom de la
nécessaire satisfaction des agences de
notation il faut dès demain augmenter de
10 % les tarifs de l'électricité
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ouvrez les
yeux au regard de la réalité sociale du
pays plus 44 % d'augmentation en 2 ans
plus 70 % d'augmentation en 10 ans ce
n'est pas supportable le droit à
l'énergie n'est pas une question de
bouclier c'est une question de droit une
question de dignité logement nourriture
soins transport éducation cela devient
inaccessible à des millions de personnes
et se dégrade pour la
plupart monsieur le Premier ministre je
ve vous le dire le réarmement
démographique ne se décrète pas il passe
par de meilleurs salaires par une
meilleure politique familiale mais aussi
par une politique de logement de hausse
des salaires qui permettent à chacune
d'entre à chacune et à chacun d'entre
nous d'entrevoir le meilleur pour nos
enfants il passe aussi inévitablement
par une école publique de qualité
véritable lieu de savoir d'apprentissage
pour leur permettre de réussir leur vie
que répondez-vous aux enseignants qui
exigent par une grève massive de main
des moyens pour l'école publique la
violente crise agricole croise
finalement toutes les autres crises une
mondialisation et une finorisation
effrainé la domination de grands groupes
qui étouffe les agriculteurs il faut
simplifier repenser l'accumulation des
normes mais il faut aussi s'attaquer au
libre échange qui promet de livrer par
cargo entier de la viande
ine de Nouvelle-Zélande ou bovine du
Brésil l'urgence c'est aider les jeunes
agriculteurs avec le retour des prêts
bonifiés à l'installation le premier
volet de la loi égalime doit être
respecté et l'État doit être le garant
du respect des agriculteurs face au
requin de la grande distribution il est
inacceptable que les agriculteurs ne
puissent vivre de leur travail et que
les consommateurs ne peuvent se nourrir
correctement et Monsieur le Premier
Ministre ce n'est pas un problème de
marché mais c'est bien un enjeu et un
choix politique Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous êtes aujourd'hui devant le
sén
qui selon la Constitution représente les
collectivités territoriales ces
collectivités territoriales ont été et
sont la dernière digue face à ces crises
multiples les élus et leur
administration y font face chaque jour
avec des moyens décroissant alors que la
demande explose difficulté d'accès aux
soins au logement difficulté de pouvoir
d'achat or quelle mesure apportera votre
gouvernement face à l'étranglement
financier progressif et à la perte de
l'autonomie financière des communes
allez-vous enfin indexer la DGF sur
l'inflation vous l'avez augmenté de 0,8
mais l'inflation est à 5 %. allez-vous
rétablir la CVAE pour faire participer
les acteurs économiques aux finances des
collectivités la commune monsieur le
Premier ministre c'est la proximité le
maillage étroit du territoire national
et de la démocratie menacer cette
institution clé de la République mais
plus profondément de notre société c'est
menacer l'édifice institutionnel déjà
vacillant oui renforcer la démocratie
locale et l'État territorial est une
nécessité pour construire les politiques
publiques indispensables au bienvivre de
nos concitoyens il ne peut y avoir de
décentralisation que si l'État est fort
assume ses missions régaliennes de santé
de sécurité de santé et d'aménagement du
territoire pour une égalité entre tous
et entre les territoire et Monsieur le
Premier Ministre pas d'hypocrisie entre
nous les élus locaux ne pourront pas
tout supporter la décentralisation
demain ne peut-être celle d'absorber les
défaillances de l'État quotidiennement
monsieur le Premier ministre le terrain
perdu que j'évoquaé d'blé c'est
évidemment celui de la démocratie votre
refus de soumettre au vote de confiance
au motif relativement absurde
permettez-moi que vous n'avez pas de
majorité accompagne de faites la main
mise totale du président de la
République sur les institutions la clé
de voûe de la 5e République ce qui en
fait un régime parlementaire c'est la
responsabilité du Gouvernement devant
l'Assemblée nationale c'est j'oserai
dire le ventre de confiance originelle
ce refus de vote augur mal de la volonté
de la dénonciation du recours au 493 qui
a marqué l'année 2023 ce n'est donc plus
au Parlement que les choix politiques se
décident mais dans les couloirs sur les
plateaux télévision sur les réseaux
sociaux ou à quelques-uns en commission
mixte paritaire écoutons écoutez
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nos
concitoyens de tous les horizons
territoires ruraux urbains et
ultramarins qui font la France et sa
grandeur ceux qui souffrent et
n'obtiennent pas de réponse face à cette
politique menée depuis 2017 que vous
avez servi avec zel nous ne pouvons en
toute logique vous accorder notre
confiance mais comme votre il n'y aura
pas vous sortirez de cet exercice par
une analyse une évaluation médiatique
alors que nos concitoyens ont plus que
jamais besoin d'une analyse et d'une
évaluation démocratique merci madame la
Présidente la parole est au président
Claude maluret pour le groupe Les
[Applaudissements]
Indépendants
président merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comme tout
chef de gouvernement vous allez
affronter de nombreux défis politiques
et le premier bien sûr et l'absence de
majorité parlementaire qui n'a permis
jusqu'à ce jour que des palliatifs
imparfaits négociation épuisant ou 493
au goût à mer le second défi est la
pression permanente et déprimante des
les extrêmes la France échappe encore à
la vague de populisme qui frappe les
démocraties parce que si ailleurs le
populisme n'est que d'extrême droite
chez nous où l'on apprend des l'école
qu'il faut préférer reespierre à
Toqueville il est coupé en deux la fin
de ces exception est proche parce qu'il
faisait le plus de bruit parce qu'il
avait réussi à embrigader une gauche en
perdition parce qu'il transformait
l'Assemblée en zone à délirer le danger
d'extrême gauche paraissait le plus
dangereux exacerbé par une caisse de
résonance médiatique qui confirme que
rien n'est plus sonore que ce qui est
creux mais la nupèe attelage improbable
de la gauche W de la gauche vébe de la
gauche caviar de la gauche stalinienne
de la gauche trotskiste et de la gauche
Hamas s'est effondré sous le poids de
ses incohérences le tegevara des calan
en cédant la direction des insoumis et
la présidence du groupe parlementaires à
des comparses choisit tous deux non pas
malgré mais en raison de leurs
insuffisances a compris tardivement
qu'il avait pris le train dans la
mauvaise direction il court depuis en
sens inverse dans le couloir à grand
geste des bras et du menton lançant ses
imprécations aux alliés comme aux
ennemis mais ne parvenant qu'à démontrer
que sa vie est devenue une interminable
rage de dents
fit c'était une surprise partie la
surprise c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
partie pas de statut pas de vote pas
d'élection juste une secte gérée par un
couple omnipotent comme les Ténardiers
tenaient le bouche de
Montfermeil le mouvement s'est fait à
rakiri le 7 octobre avec l'ignominie de
trop le refus de condamner le massacre
du Hamas qualifié de mouvement de
résistance les partenairire enrôlé dans
cette pantalonnade en en profité pour
filer à l'anglaise après que tout le
monde a
dessoulé ils resteront ceux qui ont
bradé à un emprenti dictateur les
valeurs de la gauche qu'ils ont fracturé
pour un plat lentille
électorale cet échec n'est pas qu'une
bonne nouvelle le danger s'est déplacé
dans une extrême droite qui se renforce
en proportion du déclin de son rival
porosité qui prouve que ce qui les
rapproche est infiniment plus fort que
ce qui les sépare comme Orban est devenu
l'habit de Poutine comme l'extrême
gauche italienne vote pour mélonie le RN
fait ses meilleurs scores aussi bien
dans les assébastion du PC que dans ceux
de la droite les gauchistes sont
bruyants débraillés et réclame tout tout
de suite les marinistes sont silencieux
cravatés et attendent leur heure ils
savent que face aux insoumis il suffit
de se taire pour paraître intelligent
ils n'ont aucun programme ils affichent
des convictions absolues mais si ils
n'ont aucun problème pour en changer si
elles ne vous plaisent pas comme sur la
sortie de l'euro ou le frxit ils
affirment que nous dansons sur le pont
du Titanic mais c'est eux l'iceberg ils
ont enforché tous les lir complotiste
ils ont été antivax VRP de
l'hydroxychloroine ils font aujourd'hui
le sale boulot de chien garde de Poutine
et ils le font salement ce qui n'est pas
étonnant dans ce pays fondé largement
par d'ancien collabo il dénonce la
corruption mais leurs parlementaires
européens sont mis en examen pour avoir
détourné des millions d'euros ce parti
opaque est une sorte de traboule ces
arrièrecours obscures des immeubles
Lyonnais à la façade bien propre les
anciens du GUD sont toujours là dans
l'ombre les compes racistes anonymisés
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi enfin les
deux campagnes présidentielles de marine
Poutine arrivé à son poste comme Kim
jongun par népotisme ont fourni la
preuve de sa parfaite inaptitude à la
fonction et pourtant le reflux du
populisme d'extrême gauche lui ouvre un
boulevard la photo en 2027 d'un Emmanuel
Macron raccompagné par elle sur le Peron
de l'Élysée comme Obama avait cédé sa
place à Trump n'est plus un
vraisemblable la fonction que vous
exercez aujourd'hui Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous a été confié aussi pour
faire obstacle à cette hypothèse lugueux
à cela il y a deux conditions la
première est de réussir les dou travaux
d'Hercule qui vous attendent dans un
pays tarodé depuis toujours c'est sa
grande faiblesse par le doute la hantise
du déclin et le pessimisme relever le
niveau de l'école guérir le système de
santé redonner l'espoir aux agriculteurs
poursuivre la baisse du chômage
réindustrialiser le pays réduire le
déficit construire l'Europe puissance
réformer l'État restaurer l'autorité au
sein de la société maîtriser
l'immigration assurer le développement
durable à la française je n'insiste pas
vous-même et tous les orateurs
précédents avez détaillé ce constat la
tâche est
immense je n'ai énuméré que 11 travaux
le 12e est capital mais le moins compris
le chef de l'État a évoqué le réarmement
moral économique civique il reste le
réarmement au sens propre nous sommes en
guerre c'est une très mauvaise idée
européenne d'affirmer chaque jour qu'on
ne veut pas la guerre qu'on n'est pas en
guerre lorsque vos ennemis le sont
l'international des dictateurs ne s'en
cache pas Russie Chine Iran Corée du
Nord procl qu'ils veulent abattre l'OTAN
l'Europe et l'Occident et ils font ce
qu'ils disent la guerre en Ukraine se
voit à cause des tanks et des missiles
celle qu'il nous livre cyberattaque
désinformation milliers de comptes sur
les réseaux antisociaux pour fausser les
élections abrutissement de nos enfants
sur TikTok pendant que la Chine protège
les siens et tout aussi violent elle
mine nos démocraties de l'intérieur la
Russie s'est mise en économie de guerre
notre président parle d'économie de
guerre mais aucun pays d'Europe n'est
capable 2 ans après le 24 février de
livrer à l'Ukraine ne serait-ce que les
munitions promises si l'Ukraine perd la
guerre c'est l'Europe qui la perd par
peur d'annoncer les mauvaises nouvelles
les gouvernements démocratiques ne
préparent pas leurs opinions publicque à
cette réalité lorsque j'écoute certains
d'entre eux j'ai l'impression d'entendre
le toctc du parapluie de Dadier sur les
pavés de Munich Monsieur le Premier
Ministre vous serez certes jugé sur vos
résultats dans notre pays mais à
l'échelle de l'histoire votre
gouvernement et tous les gouvernements
d'Europe seront jugés à l'ône de la
victoire ou de la défaite des
démocraties face à l'international
reconstitué des dictateurs la deuxième
condition pour qu'en 2027 au soir de
l'élection
présidentiel le visage qui paraît sur
nos écrans à 20h ne soit pas celui qui
comme ceux de Trump d'Orban ou de
bolsonaro nous fasse honte ne dépend pas
seulement de vous il est grand temps que
ceux qui se revendiquent du camp de la
raison comprennent que le temps leur est
compté s'ils ne sont pas capables de
s'unir face à des extrêmes qui nagent
comme des poissons dans l'eau des raisau
antisociaux des fake news et de l'injure
il ne faudra pas qu'ils se plaignent
d'une défaite qu'ils n'auront su
empêcher il est temps que les
raisonnables se rassemblent qu'ils
construissent une majorité ou des
alliances seule façon de gouverner la
France avec succès ce souhait sera
peut-être aujourd'hui considérer avec
indifférence ou avec ironie mais dans
quelques mois lorsque s'affichera le
résultat des élections européennes ce
qui dans la majorité comme dans les
oppositions républicaines se complaisent
dans des querelles de cours d'école
comprendront je l'espère que le temps
des anathèmes est terminé le général
MacArthur disait que les batailles
perdues se résument en deux mots trop
tard réfléchissons à cette phrase tant
qu'il est encore temps je vous
remercie merci
monsieur le
Président la parole est maintenant à
madame la Présidente Marie scarè pour le
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues si nous avons tous ici un
devoir de vérité sur la situation de la
France nous avons aussi celui de
l'espoir par nos initiatives et le
dialogue avec nos territoires il revient
à chacun d'entre nous quel que soient
nos sensibilités ou nos désaccords de
faire preuve de responsabilité et de
courage pour réparer enrichir et
préserver notre modèle social et
républicain sans méconnaître les
difficultés que rencontre notre pays
versé dans le pessimisme ou la nostalgie
d'une douce France a jamais disparu ce
n'est ni responsable ni mobilisateur
sans tout promettre nous devons
néanmoins trouver les voies pour que oui
Monsieur le Premier Ministre nos enfants
vivent mieux demain que nous ne vivons
aujourd'hui un nouveau cap pour l'emploi
l'éducation la santé le logement la
sécurité le RDSE est prêt à entendre les
nouvelles propositions à les débattre à
soutenir toutes celles qui
s'inscriraient sans détour dans le
sillon de la justice sociale de la
solidarité et du progrès vous nous
trouverez à vos côtés sur le chemin
d'une école qui tiendrait mieux son rôle
si toutefois l'uniforme n'est pas un
cache misère mais bien le signal d'un
retour aux fondamentaux de l'école
républicaine au premierers rang desquels
l'égalité des chances vous le savez mon
groupe est également attaché aux
manifestations de l'appartenance
républicaine et au respect du principe
de laïcité nous espérons la continuité
d'une certaine fermeté que vous avez
démontré sur la laïcité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre indispensable pour
protéger les consciences en éveil et
encourager l'esprit de tolérance chez
les jeunes condition du vivre ensemble
mon groupe est également attaché à une
citoyenneté réarmée pour employer vos
mots nous avons porté au débat du Sénat
des propositions que vous qu'on vous
demande de regarder nous serons
également au rendez-vous de l'écologie
comme nous l'avons toujours été pourvu
que celle-ci ne soit pas punitive mais
plutôt intelligente cohérente et
soutenable par les forces vives de
l'économie ainsi que par les plus
modestes le dérèglement climatique
nécessite une large planification des
réflexions transversales et beaucoup
d'innovations pour atteindre ses
objectifs c'est sûrement l'un des défis
les plus difficiles la crise avec le
monde agricole en est l'illustration le
RDSE a toujours défendu une agriculture
durable mais pas au prix du sacrifice de
milliers d'exploitants car c'est bien
cela qui se joue ils vous le disent
partout dans l'Hexagone et depuis
quelques jours dans les outrmers ils se
meurent quand ils ne meurent pas au sens
propre trop de normes une concurrence
étrangère déloyale la pression des
distributeurs et au bout de la haie
d'obstacle des revenus indécents alors
oui nous comprenons leur colère et nous
serons attentifs aux solutions proposées
il est d'ailleurs bien regrettable que
le travail de contrôle des
parlementaires ne soit pas davantage
regardé en l'espèce les 63 propositions
du rapport sur la détresse des
agriculteurs et bien sûr à quamp et un
véritable partage de la valeur
sur le front de l'emploi vous annoncez
un acte 2 difficile de dire à cette
heure si vous parviendrez à atteindre
votre objectif de plein emploi dans un
contexte économique mondial fragile on
ne peut que le souhaiter dynamiser le
dialogue de branche baisser les charges
expérimenter la semaine de 4 jours dans
l'administration nous regarderons avec
intérêt et vigilance tous ces projets
rendre la lumière aux travailleurs de
l'ombre dans les bureaux du secteur
public est une belle mesure et nous la
saluons il faudra pousser sûrement
jusqu'au privé sur les conditions de
travail lors de l'examen de la réforme
des retraites mon groupe a souhaité sans
être toujours entendu des mesures fortes
concernant la pénibilité Monsieur le
Premier Ministre soyez rapidement au
rendez-vous de tout ce qui constitue la
contrepartie légitime du recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite sans attendre
aussi il faut renforcer et non colmater
notre système de santé au fil des
décennies il se fracture un peu plus
avec un point d'org les déserts médicaux
quel moyen supplémentaire il en faudra
nous sommes en tout cas heureux que
notre résolution sur la santé mentale
des jeunes adopté en début d'année
trouve déjà un écho auprès du
gouvernement comment aussi espérer le
réarmement démographique promu par le
chef de l'État quand le secteur
périnatal est en danger mon groupe s'en
empare cette année par une mission
d'information sans logement pas de
projets parentaux non plus en France en
2024 des travailleurs vivent dans leurs
voiturees dans les grandes villes des
sans abri dorment sous les fenêtres des
Airbnb c'est intolérable comment ne pas
vous suivre quand vous dites vouloir
construire plus de logements et
simplifier les procédures évidemment on
ne peut pas ignorer le coût du
renforcement de toutes ces politiques
publiques aussi je m'inquiète des cibles
qui feront les frais de 12000 des 12
milliards d'économies promis pour l'an
prochain alors que beaucoup de nos
services publics sont en difficulté nous
partageons évidemment votre objectif de
redressement des comptes public mais
nous savons aussi que la question
cruciale est celle du rythme de cet
ajustement s'il est trop rapide il
pèsera sur la croissance française et
cela et cela ne fera qu'aggraver notre
dette soyez mesurés je rappellerai que
le dernier défaut de paiement de la
France date de
1797 mais j'entends bien aussi ce que
l'Europe
vous commande et nous commande auorddse
nous la portons dans notre titre car
nous la portons dans notre cœur mais ce
n'est pas un amour inconditionnel nous
l'avons démontré en faisant adopter dès
2018 une résolution sur le
Mercosur malgré ses imperfections
l'Union européenne n'est pas un problème
elle est bien souvent la solution et
vous avez rappelé Monsieur le Premier
Ministre toutes les digues qu'elle a su
construire pour protéger nos concitoyens
ils ne doivent pas l'oublier et ne pas
céder aux sirènes des populismes qui se
résument bien souvent bien souvent à la
peur de l'autre un remaniment c'est
redonner un cap cependant on ne tient
pas seul un gouvernail en cas de fortes
tempête mieux vaut s'appuyer sur les
loups de mer personne ne doute je crois
Monsieur le Premier Ministre de votre
lucidité de votre volontarisme mais les
réponses vous le savez viendront aussi
des territoires des corps intermédiaires
du monde associatif et et de tous les
élus locaux sans lesquels rien ne serait
possible des élus locaux mieux protégés
en sécurité eux aussi libérés du poids
des normes pour mieux exercer leur
mission un nouvel acte de la
décentralisation pourquoi pas si cela
consiste à redonner du souffle aux
collectivités locales pour qu'elles
reprennent en main leur destin dans
plusieurs domaines et je citerai la
compétence haut et assaainissement que
nous avons défendu ici à travers notre
proposition de loi l'intelligence des
territoires en tant que sénateur nous
sommes là pour la faire remonter dans
l'hémicycle et à à disposition du
gouvernement aussi pour terminer
permettez-moi Monsieur le Premier
Ministre d'espérer que vous trouviez la
bonne méthode que vous puissiez réussir
et ne pas décevoir vous le devez à la
jeunesse française dans sa diversité
avec laquelle vous partagez sans doute
l'audace mais pour faire remonter la
France sur le podium sans blessure
n'oubliez pas le vivier de l'expérience
je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente la parole est
maintenant au président Guillaume Gard
pour le groupe écologie solidarité
[Applaudissements]
territoire la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Premier ministre depuis 7
ans Emmanuel Macron s'efforce à
contreetemps d'imposer à la France la
mère potion néolibérale des années 80
depuis 7 ans à part pour signer des
chqus en blanc aux entreprises vous
combattez la dépense publique
appauvrissez les collectivités locales
déplumeer l'État et ampuz les servic
public depuis 7 ans vous avez enrichi
les plus riches abîmé les mécanismes de
redistribution amoindri les filets de
protection sociale et fait exploser les
inégalités vous nous annoncez la
poursuite de cette politique de casasse
sociale sans précédent en vous attaquant
au salaire minimum au minimas sociaux et
en détricotant la loi etu un premier
ministre du 7e arrondissement de Paris
et l'exécutant zellé du président des
riches tout cela coule malheureusement
de source cependant nous n'avions pas
anticipé que le plus jeune président et
le plus jeune premier ministre de la 5e
République soit à ce point non pas
conservateur mais réactionnaire la
demeure l'imposture originelle du
macronisme qui s'était d'abord présenté
comme un libéralisme chimiquement pur à
l'anglo-saxone et qui est aujourd'hui un
trumpisme élégant de Rotary Club la
pandémie mondiale la guerre en Ukraine
et la crise écologique ont achevé de
démontrer l'impasse de la mondialisation
et de votre dogmatisme néolibéral or
sans lui vous n'avez aucun cap vous vous
contentez de gérer les crises toujours
de la même manière réactionnaire
autoritaire et depuis peu populiste
Emmanuel Macron devrait permettre à
chacun de Vire de son travail 7 ans plus
tard les agriculteurs bloquent le pays
étouffés par la concurrence mondiale
déloyale et la rapacité de la grande
distribution face à une crise
structurelle dont votre idéologie est la
cause fondamentale vous vous engouffrez
dans une dérive populiste qui fait de la
protection de l'environnement et de la
biodiversité l'épouvantail des
difficultés du monde agricole vos
premières mesures n'apportent aucune
réponse pour garantir un revenu décent
aux hommes et aux femmes qui nourrissent
la France ou pour renforcer notre
souveraineté alimentaire vous vous
gardez bien de combattre le libre
échange de réinstaer des quotas ou de
répondre ou de refondre pardon une Pâque
qui engresse surtout quelques
privilégiés vous n'avez rien fait pour
reéhausser les salaires renforcer le
pouvoir d'achat des Françaises et des
Français et leur permettre notamment de
se nourrir correctement avec des
produits locaux et de qualité c'est
pourtant une des conditions sineéquanon
de la rémunération décente de nos
agriculteurs rien non plus pour
favoriser l'installation et la
transmission qui passera par une
indispensable réorganisation du travail
Emmanuel Macron avait en 2017 une
certaine vision des évolutions du
travail 7 ans plus tard cette vision
s'est perdue dans le costume gris d'un
comptable triste vous ne considérez le
travail que comme un coût en refusant
d'indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
en ne revalorisant pas les
fonctionnaires en reculant l'âge de la
retraite vous dévalorisez le travail
tout en prétendant réhabiliter la valeur
travail chercheer l'erreur Emmanuel
Macron devrait être le président du
renouveau démocratique 7 ans plus tard
faute de pouvoir se nommer lui-même il
nomme un Premier ministre qui ne
sollicite même pas la confiance du
Parlement aucun pouvoir républicain n'a
gouverné de manière aussi centralisée
aussi autoritaire avec un tel méprisu du
peuple et de tous les corps
intermédiaires voilà votre réponse à la
crise des gilets jaunes dont les
doléances sont encore sous scellé
Emmanuel Macron promettait une
République exemplaire 7 ans plus tard on
ne remanie plus pour exfiltrer mais pour
faire entrer au gouvernement des
ministres mis en examen
Emmanuel Macron avait fait de
l'éducation et de la culture son premier
chantier 7 ans plus tard vous faites
vous-même le terrible constat de la
crise du métier de professeur et vous
n'annoncez rien pour revaloriser pire
vous déployez des écrans de fumée sur
laaba vous vous égosillez sur la lïité à
l'école tout en laissant prospérer le
séparatisme scolaire de l'enseignement
privé catholique vous en faites presque
un modèle pour l'école publique en
revenant sur les acquis de Mai 68 à coup
d'uniforme obligatoire de respect de
l'autorité et de service universel ou
civique action réaction nous voici
revenu au modèle rééducatif du
tyraninique directeur Rachin dans les
coristes l'éducation punitive voilà
votre réponse à la nouvelle crise des
banlieux qui a agité notre pays l'été
dernier voilà votre réponse à notre
jeunesse enquête de sens dans le vieux
monde qui se mortisé théorisé par
gramchi ce n'est même pas une politique
de boomer c'est c'est une politique
d'avant-guerre la jeunesse de ce pays et
de ce continent se demande dans quel
monde elle vivra et vous ne faites pas
le lien avec la baisse de la natalité
déconnecté le président de la République
dans un discours que le croirait sorti
du lendemain de la Grande Guerre appelle
à réarmer démographiquement la France
sous-entendu pour faire des soldats et
des cotisants pour notre régime de
retraite vous annoncez que la santé
mentale de la jeunesse sera votre grande
cause nationale on pourrait saluer
initiative si la précédente grande cause
ne s'était pas achevée en un soutien
abject à Gérard parieux
Emmanuel grcron devait être le barrage à
l'extrême droite 7 ans plus tard il a
ouvert toutes les vannes la loi
immigration demeurera comme une
indélébile déchéance politique et morale
avant de vous présenter devant le
Parlement vous avez soigneusement
attendu un mois la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel sur laquelle vous
comptiez pour censurer les pires
atrocités de de votre pacte fustien avec
la droite extrême et l'extrême droite
mais personne n'est dupe le même
ministre de l'Intérieur incarnant votre
dérive illibérale siège toujours à vos
côtés et votre pacte de gouvernement
tacite avec les soi-disants républicains
demeure mes chers collègues de droite je
vous le dis gravement vous avez depuis
plusieurs semaines critiqué la
constitution du général de Gaulle avec
la même virulence que les héritiers de
Pétin vous êtes sur une pente glissante
qui vous mène hors du champ républicain
si vous refusez de l'entendre de ma
bouche entendez-le de celle de Xavier
Bertrand monsieur le Premier ministre je
n'ai pas encore parlé d'écologie du
moins dans la conception encilotée que
vous vous en faites mais tout ce que je
viens d'évoquer le renforcement du
pouvoir de vivre la réorganisation du
travail le renouveau démocratique le
renforcement des libertés publiques et
de l'État de droit un regard ouvert et
accueillant sur le reste de l'humanité
un projet éduc tif qui fait confiance en
notre jeunesse un projet pour lui
redonner espoir dans l'avenir c'est ça
l'écologie l'écologie est la vision qui
vous manque pour à partir des
territoires et de l'innovation locale
recréer de l'activité économique et
recouvrer notre souveraineté grâce à une
transition agricole pourvailleuse
d'emploi et rémunératrice pour les
producteurs grâce à une
réindustrialisation vertueuse concentrer
sur nos besoins essentiels et penser
dans une logique circulaire grâce à la
transition énergétique plus compétitive
et plus souveraine que le nucléaire
grâce encore à une production de
logement biosourcés économe en énergie
et reposant sur les filières locales
l'écologie est la solution pour résorber
la fracture territoriale en repensant
les mobilités l'urbanisme et en
permettant à celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent de quitter les métropoles
l'écologie est la solution pour
contrôler notre dépens publique grâce à
des investissements intelligents et à la
salobriété l'écologie est à elle seule
une politique de santé publique
l'écologie est la solution pour enfin
dépasser nos divisions nos haines nos
égoïsmes et se mobiliser ensemble dans
un objectif qui concerne l'avenir de
l'humanité tout entière l'écologie et la
solution
merci merci la parole est pour la
Réunion administrative des sénateurs
n'appartenant à aucun groupe à notre
collègue josuis
auchochard il a 3
minutes monsieur le Président Mesdames
les ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
fait une déclaration de politique
générale qui a surjoulé le volontarisme
drappé dans la nouveauté qu'inspire
votre nomination récente vous semblez
découvrir une situation dans laquelle ni
vous ni Emmanuel Macron n'auriez aucune
responsabilité un bilan dont vous ne
seriez pas comptable ainsi sous couvert
de modernité de jeunesse votre logiciel
politique est daté obsolète voilà que la
crise agricole lancinante et menaçante
depuis des décennies vous saitent à la
figure les ravages du libre échange
d'une politique bruxelloise déconnectée
des réalités du monde paysan d'un
gouvernement resté sourd au CR de colère
et de désespoir tous ces mots que le
rassemblement national dénonce depuis
longtemps vous semblez les découvrir
aujourd'hui alors que nos agriculteurs
convergent vers Paris dans un mouvement
pacifique et pleinement soutenu par les
Français Monsieur le Premier Ministre
tous ceux qui ont échoué depuis 10 ans
de gauche comme de droite vous les avez
soutenu d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous avez été incapable par idéologie et
par conformisme de résister à un libre
échange délirant comment peut-on encore
vous croire en sachant que la feuille de
route ultralibérale continuera être
déroulé dans les moouvelles années à
venir comment pourriez pourrez-vous
rétablir la la confiance alors que vous
vous êtes comptable d'aucun dirait
coupable du malheur de nos paysans
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous parlez
d'action vous accumulez les déplacements
mais vous ne pouvez rien faire parce que
vous ne vous vous libérez pas d'entraves
confortables d'entraves qui permettent
de systématiquement rejeter la
responsabilité des échecs c'est à
Bruxelles que se dciine notre politique
agricole et c'est là tout le problème
français le pouvoir politique n'existe
plus il est dilué abandonné par les
politiques eux-mêmes et nos compatriotes
l'ont bien compris Bruxelles décide et
les Français subissent c'est là c'est ce
qui caractérise aujourd'hui le système
dont vous êtes tenant c'est
l'impuissance consentie à ce titre
comment ne pas revenir sur la question
sécuritaire et migratoire sur la
poursuite en 2023 de l'immigration
massive sur la non exécution des TF avec
leur lot de drame sur les émeutes qui
ont enflammé le pays en juillet Monsieur
le Premier Ministre vous évoquez hier à
juste titre votre satisfaction de
pouvoir être Premier ministre et
homosexuel assumé en 2024 monsieur le
Premier ministre permettez-moi de sortir
de l'immédiateté et de vous poser une
question si l'xisme Sécur immigratoire
perdure pensez-vous que nous pourrons
encore assumer notre homosexualité en
2034 je l'espère et cette question me
permet de soulever le drame de nos
compatriotes qui s'aggrave chaque année
un peu plus 7 ans de macronie c'est 7
ans de précarité c'est 7 ans
d'incapacité pour nos compatriotes à se
projeter à faire des sacrifices et des
compromis parce que leur pouvoir d'achat
est laassite de mesquinerie permanente
et l'exécutoire du quoi qu'il en coûte
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous nous
avez fait l'image hier d'une France
idéale mais être français en 2024 c'est
aussi du mal à boucler ses fin de mois
et quelquefois même les débuts de mois
être ENF en 2024 c'est ne pas trouver de
place dans un dans institut spécialisé
pour y placer son enfant en situation de
handicap vos promesses Monsieur le
Premier Ministre n'y changeront rien
votre communication léchée ne nous fera
pas oublier la réalité et votre bilan
votre gouvernement demeure minoritaire
dans les chambres comme dans le pays
Monsieur le Premier Ministre prenons
date et dans 6 mois 1 an 2 ans nous
faisons le pari que rien n'aura changé
les Français veulent des acteurs au
quotidien pas les témoins du déclin je
vous
remercie merci euh la Monsieur le
Premier
Ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs je veux remercier l'ensemble
des orateurs qui se sont exprimé et qui
ont je le
crois tous été dans dans une
logique constructive je l'espère en tout
cas tourner vers l'intérêt général des
Français et et l'intérêt de notre pays
peut-être revenir sur quelques points
qui ont été
abordés je vous ai entendu monsieur
retaillot insister sur la nécessité que
nous avons de continuer à agir pour le
réarmement économique de notre pays et
qu'on soit bien clair je ne crois pas
avoir donné le sentiment tout à l'heure
ou avoir donné ce sentiment hier ou dans
mes différentes Inter intervention que
je considère que tout va mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes en France pas du
tout simplement je pense que quand ça
correspond à une réalité je pense et par
ailleurs que c'est ma responsabilité
c'est bien de dire quand il y a des
choses qui s'améliorent et la réalité
c'est que nous sommes de points en
dessous du niveau de chômage que nous
connaissions en 2017 n'a pas été aussi
bas depuis 25 ans a 2 millions d'emplois
qui ont été créés dans notre pays c'est
un succès je vais vous dire que je ne
mets même pas nécessaire au crédit je ne
dis pas que c'est le succès avant tout
du gouvernement c'est un succès
collectif de notre pays qui a réussi à
créer des emplois de nos entreprises qui
créent quand même elle les emplois on
les a accompagné on les a soutenu mais
c'est surtout un succès pour ces
millions de familles qui ont pu
retrouver un emploi et qui peuvent vivre
dans la dignité et donc moi je ne suis
pas là à dire que tout est rose
évidemment simplement je pense qu'on
peut tous s'accorder sur le fait que
tout n'est pas noir voilà et qu' a
probablement une réalité entre les deux
vous avez fait la comparaison avec
l'Allemagne c'est vrai que nous sommes
encore nettement au-dessus des Allemands
s'agissant du taux de chômage et par
ailleurs nettement a-dessus des
Allemands s'agissant du déficit et de la
dette peut aussi regarder une situation
économique aujourd'hui qui est plus
dynamique qu'en Allemagne quand on se
compare entre les deux ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement d'ailleurs une bonne
nouvelle pour nous d'avoir une Allemagne
en récession parce que ça a un impact
immédiat sur notre sur notre PIB mais
évidemment on va poursuivre on va
poursuivre les efforts
sur la la question de nos agriculteurs
moi je l'ai dit
il faut tenir et nous tiendrons cet
engagement clair pas de de
surtransposition et pas d'interdiction
sans solution ensuite vous abordez la
question de surtransposition existante
entre guillemets il y en a beaucoup
moins qu'avant puisquil y a un certain
nombre de de molécules pour lesquelles
notre pays avait fait le choix avant
2017 de les interdire mais les pays
européens ont ensuite rejoint la marche
donc je pense que le sujet vaut avant
tout pour l'avenir même si je suis très
vigilant et notamment à des situation
vous avez des molécules qui sont
interdites en Europe mais dont
l'interdiction est manifestement
contournée dans dans certains pays qui
nous entourent qui sont peut-être moins
tatillant que nous sur les contrôles et
donc c'est ça je pense que qui doit nous
animer aussi ensuite j'assume de le dire
quand nous avons une agence sanitaire
française indépendante donc je respecte
évidemment le travail mais qui de son
initiative prend une décision
d'interdiction d'un produit alors même
que le régulateur européen est en train
de se pencher sur l'interdiction de ce
produit je trouve que ça pose un
problème et qu'on doit probablement
revoir l'organisation pour que le
régulateur européen et les régulateurs
nationaux puissent parler de concert
sinon effectivement on met notre nos
agriculteurs dans une situation de
concurrence déloyale donc sur tous ces
sujets on va continuer à avancer dans
les prochaines heures on en parle tous
les jours matin midi et soir avec les
représentants des agriculteurs je veux
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur
mon gouvernement moi je crois au
dépassement politique et au
rassemblement c'est pour ça que j'ai
rejoint Emmanuel Macron en 2017 je crois
par ailleurs qu'il y a eu d'autres
moments dans l'histoire compris avec des
présidents pas si lointain ça s'appelait
l'ouverture mais en tout cas il y avait
des personnalités politiques qui
venaient d'autres formations mais
surtout surtout moi ce qui m'a convaincu
en 2017 que mettre autour de la table
des femmes des hommes qui viennent
d'horizons politique ou de partis
politiques différents pour les faire
travailler ensemble c'est pas l'exemple
des gouvernements Fillon ou autrees
c'est mon expérience de conseiller
municipal parce que s'il y a une
assemblée en France où on est capable de
se dire on n'est pas du même parti on
parfois pas de la même liste mais on
peut avancer ensemble sur certains
sujets voire même d'ailleurs avant on
est majorité opposition et puis à
l'élection suivante bah on revoit le
périmètre de la liste et la majorité on
intgre des personnes qui étaient
auparavant dans l'opposition c'est dans
nos assemblées les communales et donc je
crois profondément que ici au Sénat on
peut justement comprendre qu'on puisse
sur un certain nombre de projets voire
même pour rejoindre une majorité
s'accorder entre des personnes qui
viennent d'horizons différents c'est
vrai c'est très juste vous avez raison
monsieur le rapporteur je veux revenir
rapidement sur l'intervention de
François patria et le remercier d'avoir
mis en avant deux enjeux absolument
majeurs celui de nos outres m et de
notre réalité qui ont absolument besoin
d'un investissement particulier j'ai de
le dire dans mon intervention tout à
l'heure évidemment on va continuer à
avancer sur la question de la ruralité
je veux revenir sur le choix qui a été
fait d'avoir des stratégies beaucoup
plus proches de chacun de nos
territoires c'est les pactes régionaux
dans la Creuse les pactes territoriauxx
dans la Creuse dans la niève dans les
Ardennes dans le sraavenois tierarche
c'est le sens du plan Marseille en grand
alors ça c'est pas la ruralité mais
c'est la mais mais c'est la
territorialisation c'est la
territorialisation c'est pour ça qu'on
continue à agir je le disais tout à
l'heure pour la ruralité sur ce coup-ci
en doublant la dotation d'aménité rurale
qu'on a pérénisé les zones de
revitalisation rurale que pour les
centr-villes qui parfois se meurent on a
lancé je le disais tout à l'heure action
cœur de ville pour plus de 200 communes
qu'on a lancé peties villes de demain
pour aller aider au développement de
plus de 1600 communes quand je me
déplace et que je me rends dans des
collectivités des communes qui ont
bénéficié de ces programmes je vois tout
ce que ça a apporté à ces territoires
notamment ruraux évidemment on va
poursuivre l'investissement sur les
maisons France servic sur l'attention
qu'on porte à l'accès aux services
public dans la ruralité avec les
médicobus
les budgets que nous déployons pour le
commerce dans nos départements ruraux je
veux revenir sur l'intervention de
Madame carer et notamment sur un point
de votre intervention sur la question
euh des fins de carrière en lien avec
avec la réforme des retraites et sur la
question de la pénibilité c'est
évidemment un enjeu majeur je serais
très attentif à ce que les budgets qui
avaient été défin dans le cadre de la
réforme des retraites justement pour
prévenir la pénibilité puisse être
effectivement et soit effectivement
utilisé pour prévenir cette pénibilité
que ce soit dans l'entreprise ou dans
nos services publics et notamment à
l'hôpital par exemple ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que les partenaires sociaux négocie en
ce
moment sur le sujet de l'usure
professionnelle de l'emploi des et de la
reconversion et que j'attends beaucoup
de cette négociation et des propositions
qui pourront intervenir sur ce sujet qui
est majeur vous l'avez dit on a reculer
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite et
on l'assume totalement mais évidemment
que ça doit nous pousser à en faire
encore davantage sur la question de la
pénibilité et de l'usure professionnelle
la reconversion de nos seniors encore
une fois merci à toutes et à tous pour
vos interventions je remercie évidemment
les interventions constructives du
président Marseille du présid président
maluret également je remercie encore une
fois chacune et chacun pour leurs
expressions et je vous dis à bientôt
avec mon gouvernement pour continuer à
avancer sur tous ces sujets
là merci monsieur le Premier
ministre mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
17h45 pour la suite de la discussion de
la proposition de loi portant mesure
pour la société du Bien vieillir en
France la séance est
suspendue